Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und das hier ist Ausgabe Nummer 133 von UKW.
Okay, wir blicken auf den Kalender und der Kalender sagt 7.
Mai 2025 und nachdem es hier in der letzten Sendung um Serbien ging,
mal ganz außer der Reihe und ich mich in der vorletzten Sendung mit Enno über
die Ukraine unterhalten habe,
geht es weiter mit der Ukraine und auch ein bisschen mit der USA,
Berichterstattung und ich begrüße mal wieder den Pavel hier zurück. Hallo Pavel.
Du bist ja auch gerade im, wie heißt das jetzt, Feindesland.
An der Front sozusagen. Genau, du bist gerade in den USA, das ließ sich nicht vermeiden.
Möchtest du da was zu sagen?
Ja, nur, dass ich aus persönlichen Gründen auf einem längeren Trip durch die USA bin,
den ich jetzt nicht unbedingt aus persönlicher Neugier,
sondern weil ich eigentlich nicht Nein sagen konnte dazu,
jetzt in sieben Wochen so die halbe USA zu durchreisen.
Also so ein 10.000 Meilen Roadtrip, also so 16.000 Kilometer in sieben Wochen mit dem Auto.
Aber das gibt ja einen Blick in die aktuellen Seelenzustand der USA ein wenig auch, oder?
Ja, ja, ja. Also eigentlich erscheint hier im Alltagsleben alles normal.
Supermärkte sind gefüllt, es gibt irgendwie keine Knappheit,
es gibt kaum Proteste, also ich habe Ausschau gehalten und ja,
also die Situation ist ruhig.
Die Preise allerdings in den Supermärkten, da kommen einem schon teilweise die Tränen.
Das sind fast Schweizer Verhältnisse.
Und ja, auch für Amerikaner alles sehr, sehr teuer.
Und auch ausgehend, was nicht Pizza 30 Dollar ist, so der typische Tarif. Was?
Echt?
Oh Gott.
Wenn man ausgeht und ja, also alles teuer, alles kaputt, also schlimmer kaputt
und ja irgendwie Leute, je nachdem mit wem man redet,
sind beunruhigt und überwiegend, glaube ich, eher resigniert.
So gerade, was jetzt die Beamtenschaft angeht, die sind mehr,
überwiegend auf dem Trip ohne mich.
So, das ist da, so würde ich sagen, das Hauptressortiment und ja.
Mit ohne mich meinst du, dass sie alle kündigen oder dass sie?
Ja, die kündigen alle. Also im Zweifelsfall kündigen sie oder gehen in Rente,
weil Weil USA kann man halt nach 20 Jahren im Staatsdienst,
wenn man älter als 50 ist, in Pension gehen und kriegt dann Überbrückungsrente,
bis sie eigentliche Altersrente einsetzt.
Und ja, diese Option ziehen halt jetzt gerade ganz viele Leute.
Über die USA werden wir dann vor allem gegen Ende nochmal ein bisschen mehr sprechen.
Das bleibt natürlich jetzt beim Ukraine-Thema nicht außen vor.
Trotzdem wollen wir natürlich erstmal hier unserer Berichtspflicht gerecht werden.
Letzte Sendung, die wir gemeinsam gemacht haben, erschien am 14. März.
Was habe ich gesagt? 7. Mai. Also jetzt haben wir ja gut sechs Wochen sind vergangen. Was ist passiert?
Also insgesamt kann man sagen, militärisch hat sich die Gesamtsituation nicht
nennenswert verändert.
Front ist mehr oder weniger stabil.
Was nicht heißt, dass es keine Kämpfe gibt, die gibt es, sondern es gibt nach
wie vor sehr viele Angriffe und es gibt vor allem auch viele Angriffe hinter der Front.
Das ist ja jetzt auch nichts Neues, aber Russland setzt halt einfach extrem
viele ballistische Raketen,
Marschflugkörper und vor allem natürlich diese Schahettdrohnen ein,
nach wie vor, die sie in großer Zahl produzieren und die sie auch in großer
Zahl in die Ukraine fliegen lassen.
Und die Ziele sind halt eigentlich, naja, also von militärischen Zielen erfährt
man in der Regel nicht so viel,
aber man sieht natürlich auch, dass sehr oft große Städte, kleine Städte angegriffen
werden und es trifft irgendwie alle.
Es gab Beklagenswerte, Angriffe mit hohen zivilen Opferzahlen in Kiew,
in Rakiv, in Kherson sowieso die ganze Zeit.
Wer in die letzte Sendung zur Ukraine mit Enno reingehört hat,
da hat er ja einen Bericht abgegeben, wie es da so abgeht.
Kherson sozusagen die Frontstadt im Süden.
Aber auch andere Gebiete sind natürlich betroffen, also Saporizhia, Dnipro.
Im Prinzip setzen die Russen halt dieselbe Terror-Taktik fort,
weil sie eben auch ansonsten nichts haben.
Also immer ein bisschen schwierig aus diesen anekdotischen Berichten,
die man so konsumieren kann,
sich ein Gesamtbild zu machen, ohne selber da vor Ort zu sein,
aber es ist schon offensichtlich,
dass die Russen auf der einen Seite halt alles reinwerfen, was sie haben.
Ja, das ist vor allem halt menschliches Personal, Soldaten, Zivilisten,
also keine Zivilisten, sondern Infanterie, Infanteristen wollte ich sagen.
Aber ihnen gehen halt so die Mittel auch aus, das merkt man.
Also Fahrzeuge, es kommen in zunehmendem Maße, ungepanzerte Fahrzeuge zum Einsatz, Motorräder, Esel.
Also es ist wirklich absurd, zivile Fahrzeuge, die notdürftig zu so komischen
Kampfmaschinen umgebaut werden, kann man gar nicht so richtig nennen.
Man merkt also, dass die schon da auf ein Zahnfleisch gehen,
was so die Materialversorgung betrifft.
Aber sie haben halt von zwei Sachen eine Menge.
Sie haben eine Menge Bomben und Artillerie und sie haben eine Menge Menschen
und das ist irgendwie das, was sie im Wesentlichen zum Einsatz bringen.
Nur es führt nicht dazu, dass sich am Frontverlauf sehr viel ändert.
Das heißt, die Frontlinie über die gesamte Linie ist trotz einiger Gewinne der
Russen hier, einiger Rückgewinne der Ukrainer dort im Wesentlichen gleich geblieben.
Aber legt man jetzt zum Beispiel die von der Ukraine gemeldeten Verluste an
russischen Soldaten so als wöchentlicher Graph nebeneinander,
dann sieht man,
dass 2025 weitaus verlustreicher ist noch für die Russen, Also das verlustreichste
Jahr eigentlich bisher,
der Jahresbeginn, wir haben ja jetzt schon fünf Monate alt und das wird wohl
das Jahr mit den größten Verlusten an Personal für Russland werden, wie es aussieht.
Und wenn man den ukrainischen Zahlen Glauben schenken darf, aber das ist wie
gesagt der Vergleich und selbst wenn sie Overreporting machen,
kann man vielleicht davon ausgehen, dass sich aber die Overreportingquote nicht
verändert, sondern die Methoden mehr oder weniger gleich bleiben.
Und ja, insofern sehr blutig für Russland.
Also es gab zum Beispiel, es gibt ja so eine Organisation, wir haben gerade
vergessen, die tatsächlich zählen, wenn es sozusagen bestätigte Todesmeldungen gibt.
Also Begräbnisse, Todesmeldungen, die in Russland veröffentlicht werden,
also die wirklich jetzt nachhaltig gesichert sind.
Und allein die Zahl liegt schon bei 120.000. Ja, haben wir auch gehört.
Also das ist, die wahre Zahl wird ein Vielfaches von dem betragen.
Ja, so geht es halt hin und her. Es ändert sich auch einiges im Krieg.
Wir gehen auch gleich nochmal auf die Entwicklung bei den Waffensystemen ein,
aber vielleicht nochmal so ein paar bemerkenswerte Angriffe,
die die Ukraine auch vorgenommen hat. Also am 20.
März gab es eine ziemlich fette Explosion auf dieser Engels Air Base,
die ist ja schon ein paar Mal zum Ziel geworden.
Das ist eine relativ wichtige strategische Air Base der Russen,
wo die großen Bomber starten.
Dort ist es wohl der Ukraine gelungen, mit ihren Waffen ein größeres Waffenlager zu zerstören.
Das kann man von daher sagen, als dass die Explosionen sozusagen sehr nachhaltig waren.
Also es hat ja nicht einmal geknallt, sondern es hat einmal geknallt und dann
hat es irgendwie 24 Stunden durchgehend weiter geknallt.
Das ist ja dann immer ein sehr untrügliches Zeichen, dass man also einen größeren
Waffenvorrat zum Explodieren gebracht hat, wo dann eben sekundäre,
terziere Kettenreaktionen stattfinden.
Das war auf jeden Fall schon mal ein größerer Erfolg.
Es ist nicht immer ganz klar, was die eingesetzten Waffen sind.
Bei der Distanz müssen es halt eher schon die von der Ukraine angekündigten.
Präsentierten Mittelstrecken, Raketen sein. Also wir hatten schon mal über diese
Paglianizia-Drohne geredet, also es lässt sich auch teilweise mit den bisherigen
Begriffen schon gar nicht mehr so richtig fassen.
Tatsache ist, die Ukraine ist in der Lage mit Drohnen,
aber auch schon mit weiterentwickelten Raketensystemen immer weiter und immer
präziser tief hinter den Grenzen und tief hinter der Frontlinie zuzuziehen.
Zu schlagen und den Russen dabei schmerzliche Verluste zuzufügen.
Und genauso ging es dann weiter, dass Ukraine zunehmend halt so Ölinfrastruktur,
oder was heißt zunehmend, das machen sie ja eigentlich schon das ganze Jahr über,
bis dann, da kommen wir gleich nochmal zu, diese Scheinwaffenstillstände ausgerufen wurden,
haben sie also sehr gerne wieder so Tanklager und ölproduzierende,
weiterverarbeitende Standorte angegriffen,
nachdem sie dann das im Rahmen so einer Goodwill oder sagen wir mal,
also einem diplomatischen Verhalten geprägten Waffenstillstand angekündigt haben
oder sich da quasi dran gehalten haben.
Die Russen haben sich nicht dran gehalten, Spoiler, ja.
Aber das heißt nicht, dass sie da nicht weiter angegriffen haben,
aber dann haben sie sich sozusagen auf Fabriken konzentriert,
haben also Drohnenfabriken.
Elektronik produzierende Fabriken, Sprengstofffabriken etc.,
also alle möglichen Zuliefer-, Kleinstbetriebe oder mittelgroße Betriebe,
die halt wichtige Komponenten liefern, angegriffen.
Also es ist alles nach wie vor sehr strategisch.
Ja, der größte Erfolg war dann Ende April, im 22.
April ist es ihnen gelungen und hier ist auch noch völlig unklar,
womit ihnen das gelungen ist, aber es ist ihnen offensichtlich gelungen,
dort haben sie nochmal große Teile des Waffen, eines Waffenlagers,
also eines dieser riesigen Waffenlager.
Wir hatten glaube ich vorletzte Sendung zum Thema oder vorvorletzte Sendung
gab es ja diese ganze Reihe von Angriffen auf so riesige Waffenlager.
Also wir reden von mehrere Kilometer große Areale,
wo in Bunkern wirklich riesige Mengen an Waffen gelagert ist und zwar nicht
nur Artillerie, sondern halt auch Iskander-Raketen und so weiter.
Also das ganze Gold, was dem russischen Militär zur Verfügung steht und davon
gibt es ungefähr so 10 richtig große Standorte und nachdem sie halt vor ein
paar Monaten einige der Standorte,
die so innerhalb von ein paar hundert Kilometern.
Waren, erreicht haben und teilweise komplett zerstört haben,
teilweise angegriffen haben mit so begrenzten Erfolg, war immer nicht so ganz klar,
haben sie jetzt also das Waffenlager Barsovo erwischt und das ist halt einerseits
interessant, weil sie es halt nochmal getan haben und weil dabei ungefähr 50%
der Bunker auch zerstört wurden.
Also Bunker und sonstige Gebäude, die da waren. Es ist auch insofern bemerkenswert,
als dass eben Basowo aus der Perspektive der Ukraine gesehen hinter Moskau liegt.
Also unmittelbar hinter Moskau liegt, so 100 Kilometer entfernt.
Sprich, man würde ja meinen, dass die Luftabwehr, die Moskau schützt,
hier auch nochmal hätte zuschlagen können, aber es ist offensichtlich nicht gelungen.
Naja, das war also auf jeden Fall ein bemerkenswerter Angriff.
Genauso wie eine Serie mittlerweile von Angriffen mit den neuen Marine-Drohnen, die sie gebaut haben.
Die haben wir ja schon mehrfach vorgestellt. Das fing ja an mit diesen Kamikaze-Varianten,
die dann halt einfach Schiffe gerammt haben und versenkt haben.
Das war ja auch mit großem Erfolg.
Dann sind die Russen in zunehmendem Maße mit Hubschraubern und Drohnen mittlerweile
auch gegen diese Marine-Drohnen vorgegangen. Aber die Ukrainer haben die also
immer weiter entwickelt.
Dann gab es zwischendurch ja schon mal so die Beobachtung, dass es jetzt welche
gibt, die dann eben auch noch mit so Flugabwehrraketen ausgestattet sind.
Das Programm haben sie offensichtlich weiter professionalisiert und es gab die
Berichte vor ein paar Wochen schon, dass sie einen Helikopter abgeschossen haben.
Also von der Drohne aus, also sprich die Drohne selber, führt unter Umständen
auch gar keinen Sprengstoff mehr selbst mit sich, sondern das sind halt eigentlich
so eine Art Flugzeugträger geworden.
Einerseits für FPV-Drohnen, sodass sie quasi mit den Booten an der Krim entlangfahren,
in die Nähe von Standorten, entweder von richtigen Militärstandorten oder von
Standorten von Flugabwehr.
Und dann so die letzten paar Kilometer von der Marine-Drohne aus,
die FPV-Drohnen ins Ziel geflogen haben.
Und dann haben sie halt auch einen angreifenden Hubschrauber abschießen können.
Da kamen dann also schon andere Waffen zum Einsatz, wusste man aber noch nicht so ganz, was es war.
Und die neueste Meldung ist, dass es ihnen gelungen ist, in zwei separaten Vorfällen.
Einer bei der Krim und der andere sehr nah an Noworussiske, also das ist sozusagen
am anderen Ende des Schwarzen Meeres, Der Hafen, wo die Russen ihre verbleibende
Schwarze Meerflotte zusammengezogen haben,
dort hat so eine Magura Version 5 gespielt.
Drohne es geschafft, jeweils eine Su-30 abzuschießen.
Also eines der modernsten Kampfflugzeuge der Russen.
Ich glaube, das ist sowieso maximal zehn Jahre alt und gehört sozusagen zu den
am besten ausgestatteten Flugzeugen überhaupt.
Die mussten sich jetzt sozusagen so ein kleines Boot geschlagen geben,
die mit Sidewinder-Raketen ausgestattet waren oder so umgebauten R-73,
sogar so Sowjetabwehrraketen.
Und ja, das ist ziemlich bemerkenswert, diese Angriffe.
Vor allem ist das ja auch nach wie vor so, wir haben das ja mehrfach betont
und das kann man irgendwie auch nicht oft genug wiederholen,
es mag für die Ukraine nach wie vor scheiße aussehen, was den Frontenkrieg betrifft am Boden.
Aber den Krieg im Schwarzen Meer, den haben sie eigentlich schon mehrfach gewonnen.
Sie haben die Schwarzmeerflotte zum Drittel zerstört.
Der Rest musste sich in Novorossisk verstecken.
Schiffe fahren einfach gar keine mehr, weil die es einfach nicht lange überleben
würden. Und es bleibt einfach nur noch Kampfflugzeuge.
Also militärische Schiffe.
Ja, richtig, militärische Schiffe, das meine ich damit. Also Kampfschiffe,
also Korvetten und Zerstörer und so weiter, die sind alle weg.
Also nichts verkehrt mehr.
Also diese Dominanz, die die Russen ursprünglich ja mal über das Schwarze Meer
hatten oder haben wollten zumindest, einschließlich natürlich auch des Standorts
Sevastopol in der immer noch von ihnen kontrollierten Krim, der ist tot.
Also dieser Hafen, der ist kein Militärhafen mehr derzeit, weil dort alles einfach
versenkt wurde und letzten Endes zurückgezogen wurden.
Es wird dann hier und da in Trockendocks werden noch Schiffe repariert und auch
ein neues gebaut, aber ich vermute mal, die werden dann auch kurz vor Fertigstellung zerstört werden.
Also worauf ich hinaus will ist, die Ukraine hat es einfach geschafft mit ihrer
Drohnentechnologie im Prinzip die Russen komplett zu schlagen im Schwarzen Meer.
Also die Russen haben derzeit einfach da gar nichts zu melden. Und ja, jetzt am 9.
Mai übermorgen aus der Perspektive dieser Aufnahme sind ja die tollen Siegesfeiern
Putins in Moskau und vielleicht auch im Rest Russlands angesagt,
wo sie immer wieder den großen Sieg über die Deutschen feiern wollen,
den großen Vaterländischen Krieg und dabei ja immer fett auffahren und dieses
Jahr auch mal wieder externes Personal ranholen.
Xi Jinping ist irgendwie da und der Vujic aus Serbien und natürlich,
also ich glaube Orban selber kommt nicht, aber Ungarn ist natürlich vertreten,
der Fizo aus der Slowakei, also all die ganzen Buddies, die sie noch übrig haben Belarus,
Nordkorea Kuba Venezuela, also.
Iran glaube ich auch die sollen dann irgendwie alle da sein und sich diese Militärparade
anzuschauen, aber irgendwie in den letzten Tagen geht also ein Bericht nach dem anderen,
dass also Herrscharen an ukrainischen Drohnen gegen Moskau ziehen und das könnte
noch ganz unterhaltsam werden, was am 9. Mai dann tatsächlich abgeht.
Es könnte einerseits bedeuten, also ich glaube nicht, dass jetzt die Ukrainer
vorhaben, den Kreml anzugreifen oder so, oder diese Parade anzugreifen.
Das würde vermutlich vielleicht auch nicht gelingen.
Cool wäre eher, Wenn da so eine Drohne kommt, die einfach nur blau-gelbe Rauch
über der Parade aussprüht, das wäre wahrscheinlich der größte Propaganda-Erfolg,
den sie dort erzielen könnte.
Andererseits ist es auch so, dass Großland so Schiss hat, dass also in irgendeiner
Form diese Feierlichkeiten schief gehen könnten, gerade wenn so viele internationale Gäste da sind,
dass sie alles an Flugabwehr mobilisiert haben, um Moskau zu schützen,
was natürlich den Ukrainern die Gelegenheit gibt, zu diesem Zeitpunkt dann andere
Ziele anzugreifen, die halt dann eben nicht mehr so gut geschützt sind.
Das ist aber jetzt von mir nur eine Spekulation.
Es gab auch noch die Meldung, dass Xi Jinping bzw.
China offiziell gebeten hat, dass doch die Ukraine die Parade nicht angreifen
möge, während Xi Jinping da ist.
Und deswegen werden sie es auch nicht tun. Also ich glaube nicht,
dass sie sich den Ärger einhandeln wollen.
Stell dir mal vor, da würde irgendwas explodieren und Xi Jinping würde sterben.
Ja, ideale Möglichkeit für eine False Flag Operation.
Ich glaube, die wollen denen einfach nur Schiss machen. Die Flughäfen müssen
die ganze Zeit schließen, das spüren die Russen.
Das ist etwas, was Moskau an sich spürt. Und dann werden sie wahrscheinlich zum 9.
Mai, keine Ahnung, die Kerzbrücke versenken oder so.
Ja, also im Moment sagen übereinstimmend viele Leute so, ja,
das wird die Ukraine nicht machen oder wird es nicht wagen.
Ich meine, die offizielle Haltung der Ukraine ist, wir sind nicht für die Sicherheit
der Besucher bei der russischen Militärparade zuständig.
Oh Gott, da haben sie sich bestimmt richtig die Bäuche gehalten bei der Formulierung.
Oh Mann.
Das ist, ja, ich meine,
mache draus was wolle und es gibt dann natürlich in den Social Media dann ganz
viele, die sagen, nein, jetzt erst recht, also Ukraine soll irgendwie alles schicken,
was sie hat und unbedingt die Parade angreifen, um einfach zu zeigen, ja,
Ich meine, ja, rote Linien hatten wir die Debatte, aber nicht schon mal.
Und ja, also am Ende des Tages, was hat denn die Ukraine zu verlieren?
Die Chinesen, ich meine, wenn Xi Jinping dahin fährt in ein Kriegsgebiet,
dann ist das Xi Jinping's Problem und nicht das Problem jetzt der Ukraine. Aber ja, man wird sehen.
Ja, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie da so viel von gewinnen könnten.
Und ich denke, die Ukraine ist klug genug.
Sie denkt immer strategisch und sie denkt immer taktisch und sie denkt immer,
mit was ist für uns jetzt sozusagen das Beste und wie können wir den Russen
jetzt am meisten schaden in der aktuellen Situation.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass sie jetzt dort vor Ort am meisten Schaden anrichten
können, sondern woanders.
Und dass sie schon genug erreichen mit diesen Scare-Tactics im Vorfeld.
Also allein die Tatsache, dass die Russen sich so ins Hemd machen wegen der
ganzen Nummer, das ist ja auch schon mal ein Erfolg.
Ja, das andere Ding ist ja so,
ich meine, die russische Luftabwehr ist bekannt dafür, dass sie halt auch schon
mal Zivilflugzeuge abschießt, hat mir ja vor nicht allzu langer Zeit.
So, und wenn ich jetzt Ukraine wäre,
ich würde da schon einfach Stress und Terror machen und drauf hoffen,
dass die Russen wieder irgendwie, ja,
anfangen, Unsinn zu tun oder Fehler machen.
Gut, wird wahrscheinlich nicht passieren und ich würde noch hoffen,
dass das nicht unbedingt eskaliert, aber ich gebe da keine Prognose ab.
Ja, ich gebe auch keine Prognose ab.
Also ich halte das für möglich, dass, wie auch immer, das kann ruhig verlaufen,
aber es können auch irgendwie Dinge passieren, wenn ich der ukrainische Geheimdienst wäre.
Ich würde schon versuchen, irgendwie dafür zu sorgen, dass Dinge passieren.
Zeigen, dass der Kreml das eben nicht unter Kontrolle hat. Also wenn du jetzt
sagst, strategisch denken.
Ja, Dinge passieren, aber sie müssen ja nicht unbedingt in Moskau passieren.
Ja, also ich bin mir auch sicher, dass das, was passieren wird,
aber ich bin mir auch, ich wäre jetzt sehr überrascht, wenn es sich auf Moskau
konzentriert, sagen wir es mal so.
Also, wir werden sehen. Es bleibt spannend, finde ich.
Was man auch noch erwähnen muss, ist natürlich der Rückzug der Ukraine aus Kursk.
Wir hatten ja vor einigen Monaten diesen Vormarsch der Ukraine und lange,
lange Zeit haben hat die ukrainische Armee diesen Bereich nördlich von der ukrainischen
Stadt Sumi gehalten, um,
jetzt habe ich was Sucha gesagt, ist es Sucha, die russische Stadt,
die dort zuerst eingenommen wurde.
Man kommt bei diesen vielen Namen durcheinander.
Ich schaue einfach nochmal ganz kurz hier auf meine Karte.
Und dann wird mir hoffentlich die Karte sagen, Sucha.
Sucha hat es recht. Aber Sumi ist in der Nähe von Sucha.
Sumi ist die ukrainische Stadt, das wusste ich schon. Ich wusste jetzt nur nicht
genau, wie die russische Stadt hieß. Also Sucha haben sie als erstes eingenommen.
Sucha ist der Ort, wo diese Gaspipeline den letzten Verstärker hat und dort
dann in ein ukrainisches Gebiet überging.
Diese Gaspipelan, die jetzt nicht mehr Gas liefert nach Europa und nach Ungarn und die Slowakei.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, die Ukraine hat lange, lange Zeit dieses Gebiet halten
können und dann nicht mehr. Warum?
Naja, das Ganze fällt in die Zeit, wo es diese Unterbrechung des Intelligence-Sharings der USA gab.
Wir gehen ja gleich nochmal drauf ein, wie dieser ganze Verlauf war mit Trump
und seinen angeblichen Friedensverhandlungen und so weiter.
Dann gab es halt irgendwie diesen großen Aufreger mit dem Treffen mit Zelensky
im Weißen Haus und dann gab es halt auch noch so diesen Rückzug des Intelligence-Sharings
und diese ganze Aufregung.
Es gab vor allem so eine Woche, wo es danach aussah, als würden jetzt die USA
komplett jeden Support zurückziehen.
Und das war so eine Gelegenheit, die Russland auch genutzt hat und dort vor
allem mit ihren nordkoreanischen Truppen, aber auch mit anderen Verstärkungen es geschafft hat,
die Versorgungslinien der Ukrainer in Kursk abzuschneiden.
Erst sah es so aus, als ob die Ukraine dort das alles zurückschlagen konnte,
aber dann ist es irgendwie misslungen.
Und dann haben sie sich entschieden, sich zurückzuziehen, um keine großen Verluste zu erleiden.
Mit anderen Worten, diese Besetzung von Kursk ist beendet.
Mittlerweile gibt es Scharmützel ein bisschen weiter östlich bei Belgorod.
Das ist aber noch nicht signifikant. Da sind so ein oder zwei Dörfer hinter
der Grenze eingenommen worden und es gibt da immer wieder Auseinandersetzungen.
Und trotzdem, die Ukraine sorgt dafür, dass die Russen auch noch so ein bisschen
mit der Verteidigung ihres eigenen Landes beschäftigt sind.
Wenn gleich jetzt auch diese, ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange war denn das jetzt?
Fast ein halbes Jahr, diese Besetzung in Kurs dann beendet ist.
War auf jeden Fall ein ziemlicher Erfolg, weil es hat natürlich die Russen gezwungen,
dort eine ganze Menge Mittel zum Einsatz zu bringen.
Sie mussten sich dann auch nochmal die Russen aber auch verstärkt vom Leibe
halten, weil durch diese starke Konzentration drohte natürlich dann auch bei
dem Rückzug, dass die Russen sozusagen die Gelegenheit nutzen und dann auch
noch bei Sumi wieder ins Land einfallen.
Es gab ein paar Kämpfe an der Grenze, aber das war es dann auch.
Unter anderem musste die Ukraine dort eine F-16 einbüßen, die ist abgeschossen
worden bei den Kämpfen und auch der Pilot, Ein sehr erfahrener Pilot war, ist dabei gestorben.
Das ist jetzt die zweite F-16, die bestätigt wurde, dass die verloren gegangen
ist. Das andere war ja ein Unfall.
Ja, aber das ist sozusagen, dieses Kapitel ist jetzt erstmal beendet,
sprich die Kämpfe finden jetzt nahezu ausschließlich,
also die Bodenkämpfe finden ausschließlich auf ukrainischem Boden statt und
wie es in der Hinsicht weitergeht und ob die Ukraine nochmal in irgendeiner
Form eine Schwäche der Russen auf ihrem eigenen Gelände ausnutzen wird, das werden wir sehen.
Aber das ist so insgesamt jetzt die militärische Situation.
Ja, dann ist es auch nochmal ganz interessant, weil dieser Krieg ist,
ich will auch nochmal was zu sagen, weil wir da immer so ein Thema draus machen.
Warum reden wir über Waffensysteme? Ja,
dieser Krieg ist enorm davon geprägt, dass hier sich der Krieg auch als solcher
technisch weiterentwickelt. Das gilt zwar in gewisser Hinsicht für jeden Krieg.
Ja, das ist klar. Also wenn Krieg ist und Waffen zum Einsatz kommen,
dann wird ja vieles überhaupt erstmal getestet, was schon längst quasi in den
Lagern liegt und nie so richtig zum Einsatz kam.
Und dann stellt man halt fest, was funktioniert, was funktioniert nicht.
Und vor allem sieht man dann halt immer dieses Wechselspiel aus,
neue Innovationen kommt aufs Schlachtfeld, Gegner reagiert, denkt sich was dagegen
aus, da muss dann wieder vorgegangen werden.
Und das ist natürlich auch hier so.
Während der Einsatz von so Quadrokoptern bei der Verteidigung von Kiew ganz
zu Beginn so ein total neues Ding war und im Wesentlichen von Zivilisten angeführt wurde,
die einfach der ukrainischen Armee helfen wollten.
Ist das ja sehr schnell zu dem dominierenden Kampfmittel geworden.
Das hat den ganzen Krieg geändert, weil dieser Frontverlauf,
der ist auch deshalb so stabil, weil das ganze Kampffeld einfach transparent ist.
Also über den kompletten Verlauf der Frontlinie von über 1000 Kilometern fliegen
permanent 24 sieben Aufklärungsdrohnen von beiden Seiten.
Das heißt, so ein Gürtel von 10-20 Kilometern wird mehr oder weniger flächendeckend
von beiden Seiten permanent optisch überwacht.
Und das nicht nur jetzt optisch im optischen Bereich, sondern halt auch mit
Wärmebildkameras und weißer Geier, was sonst noch so zum Einsatz kommt.
Und das ist jetzt mal nur die Überwachung, noch gar nicht die eigentlichen Kampfmittel.
Aber das ändert natürlich die ganze Strategie.
Deswegen sind halt solche Durchbrüche selten, weil herannahende Kolonnen werden
halt schon 20 Kilometer vorher geortet und dann sind halt auch entsprechende
Abwehrdrohnen schnell im Einsatz,
fliegen die heranstürmenden Truppen an.
Und deswegen hat sich der ganze Krieg auch an der Stelle geändert,
weil die Russen eben dann sehr viel mehr auf kleine Gruppen gesetzt haben und
damit dann wieder ein paar Durchbrüche erzielt haben.
Die sind dann aber schlecht ausgerüstet, können sich dann wieder nicht lange
halten, werden dann doch nochmal irgendwie wieder aus ihren Positionen rausgebombt
und so geht es halt die ganze Zeit hin und her.
Aber aktuell gehört wohl, haben die Russen begonnen, dann tatsächlich auch die
Soldaten, die mit Motorrädern angreifen sollen, auch im Motorradfahren auszubilden.
So, ja, dass das jetzt wohl ein bisschen besser funktioniert, weil, ja,
die vorher einfach den Motorräder gegeben haben und mehr oder weniger dann gehofft
haben, dass wer auch immer darauf fährt, dass dann auch in der Lage ist,
irgendwie was damit zu tun.
Aber ja, mittlerweile bilden sie wohl tatsächlich wie Motorradangriffstruppen
aus, was ich ziemlich bitter finde.
Naja, das ist bitter vor allem, weil die natürlich von den Drohnen nicht nur
schnell ausgespäht werden können, sondern eben auch gut bekämpft werden können,
weil sie sozusagen überhaupt keinen Schutz haben.
Ja, aber es ist wohl besser als zu Fuß.
Ja, schneller.
Ja, also die Chancen, irgendwie davon zu kommen, so sind deutlich besser,
wenn sie ein Motorrad dabei haben, als wenn sie, weil zu Fuß hast du einfach
da überhaupt gar keine Schnitte.
Ja, aber das Problem ist...
Wie weit können sie kommen und was machen sie da, wenn sie da sind?
Weil du musst ja im Prinzip auch einfach nur irgendwo drei Kilometer weiter
vorne zu sein mit fünf Leuten,
das hilft dir nicht viel, damit nimmst du noch keine Stellung ein,
sondern du musst ja dann auch Versorgung haben, brauchst ja Nachschub und all
das, das funktioniert ja alles gar nicht.
Ja, das sind jetzt nicht eigentlich keine guten Waffen irgendwie,
um damit an der Front dann anzugreifen, so Motorräder.
Aber ich glaube, ich hätte lieber ein Motorrad als kein Motorrad,
wenn ich in der Situation wäre.
Als Motorradfahrer musst du das ja auch sagen. Na gut, ich wollte aber eigentlich
auf die Drohnen nochmal zu sprechen kommen, weil was ja, das ist ja auch schon
ganz zu Beginn, ich glaube wir hatten mal sogar so einen Titel,
Kampf ums elektromagnetische Spektrum.
Also der Kampf in den elektromagnetischen Wellen, der wird hier hart geführt
und Jammer-Systeme, also Electronic Warfare-Systeme, sprich Abwehrsysteme,
Drohnenstörsysteme, die sind halt weit verbreitet.
Und die Russen sind da auch relativ gut unterwegs.
Und beide Seiten setzen in zunehmendem Maße auf Drohnen, die mit Glasfaserkabeln gesteuert werden.
Das klingt ja erstmal so ein bisschen absurd, was eine Drohne,
die irgendwie 10 Kilometer weit fliegt und da ist dann irgendwie so ein Schwanz
dran. Wie soll denn das funktionieren?
Naja, Glasfaserkabel stellt sich heraus, ist halt auf der einen Seite ausreichend
reißfest, kann halt sehr hohe Datenraten übertragen und wiegt halt auch wenig
und kann halt sehr dünn gebaut werden.
Mit anderen Worten, diese Drohnen fliegen los und wickeln die ganze Zeit hinter
sich dieses Glasfaserkabel ab,
über das die Drohnen halt gesteuert werden können, sodass sie nicht auf Funk
angewiesen sind, sodass sie wiederum von solchen Electronic Warfare-Systemen
nur insofern beeinflusst werden können,
als dass jetzt unmittelbar die Elektronik gestört wird.
Aber das ist eigentlich selten der Fall, sondern es geht ja eigentlich immer
primär darum, dass die Kommunikation gestört wird.
Und mit diesen Glasfaserkabeln wird das eben verhindert.
Aber das ist, wie gesagt, eine Technologie, die auch auf russischer Seite zum
Einsatz kommt. Und ich habe auch gehört, dass das eine größere Rolle gespielt
haben soll bei der Rückeroberung von Kurs. Das weiß ich aber nicht genau.
Also Fotos zumindest auch von Gegenden gesehen, wo du dann hunderte von Kabeln
siehst, die dann so aussehen wie so ein Spinnennetz, was so in der Sonne glitzert oder einzelne Fäden.
Und was ich auch gehört habe, ist, dass eine Waffe, eine Gegenwaffe entwickelt haben,
wo sie dann, wenn sie dann so eine Glasfaser haben,
irgendwo, also die dann liegen bleibt von der Drohne,
dass dann dort einen Laser anklemmenden, sehr hellen, der die Glasfaser so weit
illuminiert, dass dann wohl aus der Luft zu sehen ist, wo die halt langgelaufen ist.
Und dass man auf diese Art und Weise dann quasi rückverfolgt,
von wo aus die gestartet wurde.
Es ist mir zwar unklar, wie das funktionieren soll, Aber ja,
angeblich soll es das jetzt geben.
Ja, also dieses ganze Drohnen-Geschäft, also Ukraine ist mittlerweile,
denke ich mal, führend, was so verschiedenste Drohnensysteme betrifft.
Und ich habe es ja auch schon gerade eben berichtet, diese Marine-Drohnen,
die also quasi wie so eine Art Flugzeugträger für andere Drohnen funktionieren.
Ähnliches gab es ja auch vorher schon seit einiger Zeit mit so Großflugdrohnen,
die dann wiederum kleinere Drohnen haben.
Also dieses Huckepack-System wurde zuerst mit Drohnen selbst gemacht,
dann eben jetzt auch mit diesen Booten.
Und ja, die Erfolge sind halt ganz offensichtlich.
Ich denke, in dem Bereich werden wir einfach noch eine ganze Menge sehen.
Das Ganze hat jetzt auch dazu geführt, dass es auf der ganzen Welt,
aber auch in Deutschland jetzt jede Menge Startups gibt,
die irgendwie dort mitspielen wollen, also im Bereich Kampfdrohnen.
Also es gibt mittlerweile hunderte von Firmen, auch außerhalb der Ukraine,
die halt Investoren angezogen haben und jetzt eine Menge Geld haben,
um da Drohnen zu entwickeln und zu produzieren.
Und der letzte Trend ist halt nicht Drohnen zu bauen, sondern Drohnenfabriken.
Also Drohnenbaumaschinen ist jetzt der letzte große Trend.
Du hast ein paar Container, die du anlieferst und die fangen dann an, Drohnen auszuspucken.
Das ist irgendwie der letzte Trend.
Ja, also die Industrie, eine richtige Drohnenindustrie.
Und jetzt auch vor allem, ich meine, die Nummer mit diesem Magura V5 und dem Abschuss der SU-30.
Das ist sozusagen mit einem Boot und mit einer Sidewinder-Rakete,
die normalerweise so an Flugzeugen dran ist, um andere Flugzeuge abzuschießen.
Das sind eigentlich Luft-Luft-Abwehr-Raketen.
Mit dieser Kombination, wo halt, ich weiß nicht, was dieses Boot,
die Ukraina kostet, das wird nicht viel sein.
Aber diese Raketen, gut, das sind halt teilweise auch noch sehr alte Bestände,
aber ich weiß nicht, was sie für einen Wert haben.
Vielleicht eine Million, fünf Millionen oder sowas.
Also die alten Sidewinder, so aus Altbeständen, kriegt man wahrscheinlich so
für 50.000 bis 100.000 Dollar,
kostet mal mehr.
Dann Iris-T ist ja auch dieselbe Klasse von Systemen, ein paar hunderttausend.
Also das ist so die, für die eigentlichen Luft-Luft-Raketen,
also deutlich unter einer Million jedenfalls.
Das Ganze ist halt fünf bis zwanzig Stück für eine Million ungefähr.
Mit anderen Worten, ein so ein Boot mit zwei solchen Raketen,
den Launcher-Systemen, der Elektronik und so weiter, kriegst du wahrscheinlich
für eine Million gebaut.
Und mit diesem Teil haben sie halt irgendwie so einen 50 Millionen Fighter aus der Luft geholt.
Und damit gibt es auf einmal eine komplett neue Bedrohungslage für Kampfflugzeuge,
die sie so vorher noch nicht auf der Kette hatten, weil bisher war halt nur
Bodenluft im Sinne von aus stationären Abwehrsystemen oder vielleicht aus mobilen, aber eben nicht.
Zu jedem Zeitpunkt eben fest stationierten Abwehrsystemen wie Patriots und so weiter,
oder eben aus anderen Flugzeugen, das waren so die Bedrohungen,
aber dass er jetzt einfach so ein Boot irgendwie übers Wasser tümpelt und dann
auf kurze Distanz die abschießt,
das ist halt komplett neu und das ist eine Technologie, die sozusagen jetzt
derzeit nur die Ukraine hat.
Man muss ja sagen, diese Sidewinder-Raketen, wenn die halt von einem Flugzeug
abgeschossen werden, dann haben die eine ganz andere Reichweite,
das ist glaube ich bei 20 Kilometer,
aber wenn sie halt unten von dem Boot aus geschossen wird und damit sozusagen
auch nicht schon mal die Geschwindigkeit des Flugzeugs hat und dann auch noch nach oben steigen muss,
ist die Reichweite halt nur noch bei der Hälfte.
Mit anderen Worten die Detektion des Flugzeuges von der Magura-Drohne,
von dem Boot, die muss so gut sein und so schnell sein, dass sie halt auf kurze
Distanz, ich meine so ein Kampfjet, wie lange braucht der, um 10 Kilometer zu
fliegen? Nicht lang, ja.
20 Sekunden.
Genau, also das ist Sekundenentscheidung.
Und diese Detektionsfähigkeit dort eingebaut zu haben und erstmal zwei Wochen
über das Schwarze Meer kuttern zu lassen, um dann so ein Ding aus der Luft zu
holen, das ist schon wirklich bemerkenswert.
Schauen wir mal, was jetzt im Bereich der Flugzeuge, die ja natürlich nach wie
vor ihre Bedeutung haben, passiert.
Also wir hatten ja die Mirage 2000 Lieferung aus Frankreich.
Da habe ich so ein bisschen den Überblick verloren, aber da muss sicherlich
auch erstmal nochmal viel trainiert werden, aber das wird auf jeden Fall weiterhin
stattfinden, wenn es nicht sogar schon stattgefunden hat.
Aber ich habe bisher noch von keinen Einsätzen gehört.
Die Franzosen sind auf jeden Fall bereit, ihre ganzen Restbestände da abregnen zu lassen.
Dann sehr wichtig, glaube ich, auch für den weiteren Verlauf,
wir hatten das auch schon mal angekündigt irgendwann, als das erstmalig gemeldet
wurde, jetzt sind sie auch geliefert worden, die Saab 340.
AEWCS das steht für Airborne Early Warning and Control oder wir kennen das von
den Amerikanern als AVAX-Systeme, genau.
Also das sind relativ keine Boeing oder so. Die Amerikaner haben das ja so in richtig groß.
Das ist ein verhältnismäßig kleines Flugzeug, wo dann oben so ein Radar drauf ist.
Das ist auch mittlerweile kein Rotationsradar mehr, sondern das ist halt so ein.
Fasen, Radar, was halt einfach wie so ein Balken aussieht, der oben auf dem
Flugzeug drauf montiert ist.
Mit diesen beiden Flugzeugen kann die Ukraine aus dem Zentrum des Landes heraus
den gesamten Frontbereich überwachen.
Und das ist natürlich bemerkenswert, weil jetzt hat sozusagen die Ukraine das
erste Mal eigene Luftaufklärung und da fällt mir auch nochmal ein,
Also vor einigen Monaten ist es ja gelungen,
der Ukraine die A-50 Flugzeuge der Russen, die halt was ähnliches machen, abzuschießen.
Da auch in der Gegend um Novorossisk und seitdem fliegen die halt nicht mehr
so nah an die Ukraine ran.
Also da hat jetzt die Ukraine in gewisser Hinsicht einen Aufklärungsvorteil gegenüber den Russen.
Und es sind wohl jetzt auch weitere, da wurde explizit keine Zahl genannt,
aber es wurden weitere F-16 geliefert.
Das sind ja die, die aus Holland und aus Dänemark vor allem kommen und was jetzt
auch noch bestätigt wurde, ist, dass die Schweden jetzt die Gripenflugzeuge
auch noch an die Ukraine liefern.
Die kommen definitiv aus Schweden, weil nur die Schweden haben welche über.
Andere Länder haben die aber das ist dann sowas wie Ungarn und so,
die rücken natürlich sowieso nichts raus und die haben auch relativ moderne
Systeme haben die auch noch nicht so lange und haben also definitiv auch keine,
die schon ausgemustert werden deswegen werden die aus Schweden kommen,
die Gripen werden ja noch weiterhin gebaut und ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass die Auftragsbücher der,
Gripenproduktion auswählen
Sehr voll sind jetzt.
Die Tschechen haben auch welche.
Genau, also das ist schon so ein bisschen auch der heiße Kandidat,
haben wir uns ja hier auch schon mal drüber unterhalten, für eine Aufrüstung der anderen Art.
In dieser ganzen Debatte mit F-35, ja das ist das totale super Flugzeug und
kann alles und das super Stealth und hast du nicht gesehen.
Und die Israelis haben ganz viele davon und setzen die auch sehr erfolgreich ein.
Aber wenn du halt als Europäer die kaufst, dann hängst du halt einerseits sehr
von den USA ab und andererseits sind halt die Betriebskosten der F-35 halt extrem groß.
Man hat ganz davon abgesehen, dass halt die Ukraine die eh nicht bekommen würde.
Zumindest nicht in dem aktuellen politischen Dickicht.
Beim Kaufpreis unter ist, liegen die fast gleich auf.
Also wenn man die Bank kauft, das finde ich sehr interessant,
was damit zu tun hat, dass eben die F-35 bisher in riesigen Stückzahlen vergleichsweise
gebaut wurde schon und deswegen so viel günstiger geworden ist.
Die F-35 ist der Preis, hat sich halbiert gegenüber am Anfang.
Könnt ihr mir durchaus vorstellen, dass die Gripen sich demnächst auch sehr
viel billiger produzieren lässt, weil so viele gebaut werden?
Und die Kanadier wollen ja jetzt auch welche Stadt, irgendwie alle F-35 und
Vorteil ist dann wohl auch, dass sie einen Großteil davon selber bauen können.
Also die Schweden lassen die dann auch in Kanada fertigen, so das ist dann natürlich
auch ein Riesenvorteil noch, wenn du die kaufst, wenn du die dann im Land bauen
kannst oder ein Großteil davon.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall sehr interessant und es ist noch nicht klar,
wann die kommen. Da muss natürlich auch mal eine Ausbildung stattfinden.
Ich will jetzt auch nicht mehr so viel darüber reden. Wir haben schon mal ausführlich
die Technologie vorgestellt.
Hauptvorteil ist halt niedrige Betriebskosten und vor allem ein krass reduzierter
Wartungsaufwand, weil man für die halt keine Hightech-Standorte braucht,
wie auch für die F16 und damit natürlich auch für die F35.
Sondern die kann man quasi auf jedem Wald- und Wiesenflughafen mit einem Trupp,
der mit einem Bus mit einer großen Handtasche vorbeikommt kann man die irgendwie
auch schon warten und reparieren dafür sind sie gebaut das ist sozusagen das
Prinzip dieser Gripen aber vor allem unterstützt die Gripen halt auch alle modernen
europäischen Waffensysteme wie zum Beispiel IRIS Ja,
also die Luftabwehr,
welches Unternehmen stellt das nochmal her?
Iris T aus Deutschland.
Ich kann sie immer alle nicht auseinanderhalten.
Ja, nicht.
Deal.
Genau, Deal war das.
Und auch die MBDA Meteor. Also MBDA ist ja der große Militärkonzern von,
was steckt da alles drin?
Airbus, genau, die Airbus Group und das ist sozusagen das europäische,
große europäische Missilesystem.
Und die Meteor ist halt insofern sehr interessant, als dass das eben nicht so
eine Fire-Once und dann gucken wir mal, ob sie ankommt, Rakete ist,
sondern das ist so ein zuschaltbares Strahltriebwerk,
was halt also nochmal sehr viel feiner Verfolgung vornehmen kann.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, all diese Waffensysteme können mit der Gripen genutzt werden in Zukunft.
Außerdem hauen die Franzosen noch größere Produktionsmengen,
Von diesen AASM Hammer Gleitbomben raus, die die Ukraine in der letzten Zeit
sehr erfolgreich zum Einsatz gebracht hat.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen die Antwort auf die Gleitbomben,
die die Russen jetzt lange Zeit so in Vorteil gebracht hat.
Einerseits haben die Ukrainer wohl ganz erfolgreiche Abwehrmaßnahmen entwickelt,
um gegen diese Gleitbomben vorzugehen, sind aber nach wie vor ein Problem, gar keine Frage.
Aber jetzt haben sie sozusagen mit diesen ASM Hammer Systemen auch ähnliche
Schlagkraft und es gibt immer wieder mal Berichte, wo die zum Einsatz kommen,
um so größere Standorte abzuräumen,
also die auch besonders verbunkert sind etc..
Ja, dann kann man auch hinzufügen, Deutschland hat jetzt nochmal vier IRST-Systeme
geliefert und vier neue oder wird liefern.
Ich bin mir gerade nicht ganz so sicher, ob die schon da sind oder ob die noch
kommen, aber das ist auf jeden Fall zugesagt.
Und große Überraschung, es kommt noch ein weiteres Patriot-System und diesmal aus Israel.
Ja, refurbished.
Refurbished, aber ist schon interessant. Israel ist schon einen Schritt weiter.
Patriot gilt ja immer so ein bisschen als das Modernste und Beste,
was man haben kann. Die Israelis wohl anders, weil die haben natürlich ihr eigenes System.
Vor allem haben die Israelis nicht nur ihr eigenes System, sondern die haben
ja so eine Triade aus Abwehrsystemen für den Ultranah-, Nah- und Fernbereich.
Und das Besondere ist, dass die halt alle zusammenarbeiten.
Also sie haben sozusagen so ein Verbundsystem für die Abwehr auf allen Ebenen
und das ist halt sowohl, Rakete fliegt
aus Gaza an und man hat nur wenige Sekunden zu reagieren bis hin zu,
Rakete fliegt aus Jemen auf Israel zu und man will das abwehren.
Funktioniert auch nicht immer alles, wie wir gerade gesehen haben.
Die Rebellen haben es geschafft, eine Rakete tatsächlich auf dem Ben-Gurion-Airport
explodieren zu lassen. Das ist ein First.
Das ist auch ein bisschen peinlich, aber naja, nichts ist halt perfekt.
Aber dieses Patriot-System, was Israel nicht mehr braucht,
wird halt, wenn es fertig überarbeitet worden ist, in die Ukraine überführt
und das ist insofern ein Novum, weil es bisher noch überhaupt gar keine Waffen
aus Israel, zumindest nicht offiziell aus Israel in die Ukraine gegangen sind.
Ja, wobei das geht auch erstmal offiziell in die USA zurück und dann kommt es aus den USA.
Sie können immer auch sagen, wir haben es einfach nur in Zahlung gegeben.
Beim Händler.
Das kann ich ja gebraucht. Flugabwehr, Zahlung gegeben.
War das letzte Preis. Anyway, auf jeden Fall bedeutet das, dass die Ukraine
damit zehn Patriot-Systeme im Einsatz haben wird.
Vor einem Jahr gab es ja noch den Ruf von Zelensky nach mehr Patriot-Systemen.
Und da gab es so die Aussage mit, wir brauchen Acht, um die Ukraine zu schützen.
Jetzt ist immer mehr auch gut so und Dinge müssen ja auch gewartet werden und so weiter.
Und dass sie noch mehr Abwehrbedarf haben, steht ja auch vollkommen außer Frage.
Trotz allen Widerständen tut sich aber auf jeden Fall auch in diesem Bereich etwas.
Ja und die letzte gute Meldung in diesem Zusammenhang ist, dass jetzt die USA
tatsächlich, da kommen wir jetzt eh gleich nochmal dazu,
mit diesen ganzen Waffenlieferungen, es hieß ja lange Zeit USA unterstützt die Ukraine nicht mehr.
Mittlerweile dreht sich so ein bisschen der Wind wieder und es gab eine Zusage
über 50 Millionen US-Dollar Wert einer von Waffenlieferungen und dazu gab es
dann auch noch die Meldung,
dass so in der Größenordnung von 300 Millionen US-Dollar ausrangierte F-16 an
die Ukraine geliefert wurden.
Also die sind in Polen und auf diesem Flughafen, der in der Nähe von Lviv ist,
dass die dort gesehen wurden.
Also sozusagen kaputte F-16 ohne Motor und so weiter.
Die haben sie alle dahin geschafft als Reparaturmateriallager und in diesem
Deal ist aber auch noch Training mit drin.
Das heißt, es werden auch ukrainische Piloten an der F-16 ausgebildet in den USA.
Was auch nochmal eine interessante neue Wendung ist in diesem ganzen Spiel von
hat die USA die Ukraine jetzt noch lieb oder nicht.
Ja, ich meine, diese Geschichte mit den F-16-Teilespendern angeblich ist,
ich meine, ja, das gab es halt auch schon mal, wobei es halt schwer zu unterscheiden
ist, wenn da ein Haufen Teilespendern kommt,
wie viele möglicherweise komplett neue F-16s lassen sich daraus zusammenbasteln.
Also im Grunde genommen ist das ja, wir schicken irgendwie Ersatzteile und die
werden dann zu Flugzeugen wieder zusammengebaut, diese Ersatzteile.
Aber ja, man redet halt offenbar nicht so gerne darüber, sondern liefert lieber.
Das Interessante vielleicht noch an den Patriot-Systemen, weil du sagtest zehn Stück.
So die Bundeswehr, also Deutschland hat zwölf, hat drei davon an die Ukraine
abgegeben und hat dann jetzt neun.
Das heißt, die Ukraine könnte jetzt ein Patriot-System mehr haben als Deutschland.
So das noch vielleicht als eine Anekdote.
Die brauchen die aber auch dringender als wir.
Ja, ja, ja. Aber man könnte auch sagen, ich meine, Deutschland hat neun Stück
und hat die noch nie benutzt.
Also außer zur Ausbildung vielleicht, aber...
Man darf doch wohl noch mal Angst haben.
Ja, aber man könnte die ja auch vielleicht ein bisschen weiter nach Osten rüberschicken,
um dann die Raketen früher abzufangen, die sich möglicherweise verfliegen oder
zu nah an die deutsch-polnische oder an die NATO-Grenze rankommen,
wäre ja auch mal eine Variante.
Gut, kommen wir weg von den Waffensystemen als Seuchen und hin zu dem Konflikt
im Ganzen und das ist natürlich vor allem in den letzten sechs Wochen der Konflikt
gewesen zwischen den USA und der Ukraine.
Ich glaube, so kann man das ganz gut formulieren und speziell sollten wir vielleicht
nochmal genau auf diesen Stopp der Waffenlieferungen schauen.
Also es gab ja dieses ominöse Treffen im Oval Office,
haben wir jetzt schon mehrfach erwähnt, jeder weiß es, was halt wirklich absurd
verlaufen ist und was sagen wir mal auch so ein bisschen zusammen mit Trumps
Zollpolitik dazu geführt hat,
dass eigentlich Europa quasi die USA derzeit nicht mehr als vollwertigen Partner
ansieht und als Putin vielleicht nicht unbedingt als Feind,
aber zumindest sich eine Neuorientierung Europas und auch des Restes der Welt,
einschließlich Kanada und auch einiger anderer Länder,
anbahnt, beziehungsweise schon auch abzeichnet.
Und in diesem hin und her gab es
ja dann eben diesen Moment des Stopps der Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine,
ja also da wurde dann sozusagen nichts mehr nach Polen geflogen und im Detail
war das ein bisschen unklar,
und jetzt sieht es so aus als ob das irgendwie noch nicht mal wirklich eine
Entscheidung von Trump war,
der wahrscheinlich sowieso kaum irgendwas entscheidet. Ich meine,
der spielt doch die ganze Zeit Golf.
Ja, also es passt zumindest irgendwie in das Narrativ.
Und die New York Times hat jedenfalls vermeldet, dass der Stopp der Waffenlieferungen
an die Ukraine ein Alleingang von P. K. S.
Gewesen sein soll, also dem US-Verteidigungsminister.
Angeblich sollen die irgendwie allgemein Dinge diskutiert haben.
Und was H. S. irgendwie mitgenommen hat für sich aus dem Gespräch,
ist, der Präsident möchte nicht mehr, dass Waffen an die Ukraine geliefert werden.
Und hat dann kürzerhand mündlich den Befehl gegeben,
es unverzüglich einzustellen und hat aber niemandem auch irgendwas gesagt,
dass er das jetzt will oder wo er doch sonst eigentlich ganz gut ist,
im Signal-Chat alle möglichen Informationen zu streuen,
war halt dieses mit der Einstellung so,
ja, hat irgendwie den Befehl gegeben, mündlich und ja,
sonst im Weißen Haus seit der politischen Ebene niemanden informiert und die
Ukraine wunderte sich dann und was ist jetzt los und fragte dann beim Weißen
Haus nach und drei Tage lang war niemand in der Lage, ihnen Auskunft zu geben,
was los ist, weil niemand irgendwie wusste, was los ist.
Also musste dann erstmal dann alle nachforschen.
Also das ist jedenfalls das, was die New York Times behauptet, wie es gelaufen,
sein soll und wenn das alles stimmt, dann würde das bedeuten,
dass die Wiederaufnahme des Intelligence Sharing und der Restwaffenlieferung,
die waren ja damals dann,
war ja haufenweise Waffen mitten im Transit und standen dann irgendwo oben plötzlich
und die sind dann ja dann auch alle dann noch ausgeliefert worden,
also dass das dann unterwegs hängen geblieben war.
Und wenn das jetzt stimmt, Und dass das wirklich so war, dass das wirklich irgendwie
ein Missverständnis war, dann wäre halt diese Wiederaufnahme der Waffenlieferungen
und von Intelligence-Sharing zumindest gar kein Meinungsumschwung von Trump gewesen,
sondern nur eine Korrektur eines Fuck-Ups, die aber dann eine Woche gedauert hat.
Und man muss natürlich immer vorsichtig sein.
Ich war nicht dabei. Ich habe es jetzt persönlich ganz jetzt nicht verbürgen, dass das so war.
Aber New York Times ist jetzt nicht unbedingt jemand, der Dinge einfach so schreibt.
Das heißt, die haben sicherlich Leute, die denen das berichtet haben.
Aber das Ganze könnte natürlich trotzdem auch Desinformation sein,
um den Versuch, den Vertrauensschaden zu begrenzen.
Und von Trump abzulenken und zu sagen, das war nie unsere Absicht.
Das war nur ein Missverständnis.
Aber am Ende des Tages ist der Schaden angerichtet, weil faktisch ist es egal, wie es passiert ist.
Weil es ist passiert und es kann wieder passieren.
Und dann ist die Frage, ob ein Präsident, der ständig seine Meinung wechselt
oder einer, der halt völlig inkompetente Leute auf Führungspositionen setzt,
wo sie irreparable Schäden anrichten können.
Das Ergebnis ist am Ende gleich und kann davon ausgehen, dass dieser Fuck-up
die Rüstungsindustrie, die amerikanische, hunderte Milliarden an zukünftigen
Aufträgen gekostet haben.
Vielleicht sogar Tausende von Milliarden, das kann man noch gar nicht abschätzen.
Allein dieses Ding, diese Lehre, okay, wenn du von den USA Waffen kaufst und dann im Krieg bist.
Dann kann die USA dir einfach dann deine Waffenlieferungen abstellen,
wenn sie da keinen Bock drauf hat.
Oder wenn irgendjemand einfach offensichtlich irgendwas missversteht,
so sind es plötzlich, sterben plötzlich Leute bei dir.
Also das ist so das schlimmste Vertrauensschaden, den man dem amerikanischen
Waffengeschäft nur zufügen kann.
Und insofern, ja, also unglaublich, so was da, ja, wir versuchen halt jetzt,
ja, Inkompetenz durch Missverständnis oder, also, schlimm.
Ja, also die Inkompetenz ist wirklich krass.
Am 25. März kam ja dann auch noch dieses Signalgate in die Öffentlichkeit.
Das muss man in dem Zusammenhang ja auch nochmal erwähnen.
Da ging es jetzt zwar erstmal nicht um die Ukraine, sondern es ging halt um
einen Angriff auf die Houthis.
USA haben ja verschiedene Angriffe auf die Houthis geflogen, auch jüngst nochmal.
Da geht es ongoing, ist auch immer noch, also wird es nicht...
Ja, es ist ongoing. Jetzt gibt es gerade Berichte, dass die Houthis irgendwie
zurückziehen, aber sie sagen ja auch nur mit, wir greifen jetzt keine Schiffe
mehr an, aber Israel greifen wir trotzdem noch an.
Und ich glaube, Israel ist jetzt auch gerade nicht gerade besonders amused wegen
dieser Ben-Gurion-Geschichte.
Also da wird es noch heftig knallen. Wahrscheinlich knallt es gerade,
während wir hier diese Sendung aufnehmen.
Aber was halt dieses Signalgate und jetzt eben auch diese Aufdeckung,
dieser Waffenlieferung und so weiter zeigen und wie eigentlich auch fast jede
öffentliche Äußerung von Pete Hexeth und den anderen Vögeln,
die Trump da halt in diesen Sicherheitsbereich gebracht hat und diesen militärischen
Komplex der US-Regierung reingebracht hat,
zeigt einfach, was das alles für Anfänger sind. Also vor allem dieser Hexess.
Ich meine, dieser Hexess ist so ein Fernsehmoderator.
Ja, ja, Fernsehmoderator, aber die haben teilweise durchaus gedient.
Also sie waren tatsächlich, sagen wir schon, also auch Hexess war,
glaube ich, beim Militär.
Ja, aber nicht lange. Und die haben da auch keine nennenswerte Karriere gemacht
und vor allem würden sie ja auch nie wieder reinkommen.
Felix ist irgendwie ein Alkoholiker und fällt halt einfach mit seinem ganzen
Verhalten ja auch immer noch sehr unangenehm auf und hat im Wesentlichen auch
überhaupt gar keine administrative Erfahrung,
jetzt irgendwie das größte Militär der Welt, also die größte Organisation der Welt zu führen.
Das merkt man ja an diesen ganzen Maßnahmen und seinen Äußerungen auch ganz deutlich.
Dieses Signalgate, wo sie halt dann dieses Prinzipal Committee,
also alle Leute, die quasi zu diesem Sicherheitszirkel gehören,
die USA so hatte, halt irgendwie, was weiß ich,
Verteidigungsminister und verschiedene Leute, sozusagen die in irgendeiner Form
für Sicherheitsmomente der USA dann verantwortlich sind,
die sollen halt miteinander kommunizieren in diesem Principal Committee und
dann haben sie halt dafür irgendwie ein Single Group Chat aufgemacht und.
Haben ja sicherlich auch alle schon gehört von dieser Story.
Das war ja einfach auch überhaupt nicht zu übersehen.
Zeigt bloß halt einfach auch nur, wie schlecht diese Truppe aufgestellt ist.
Also es sind einfach Leute, die nicht genau wissen, was sie tun und dabei keinen Style haben.
Und es wird halt in absehbarer Zeit wieder zu irgendeinem Unfall kommen,
einfach weil die sich überhaupt nicht im Griff haben.
Ja, also als einzige wirkliche Konsequenz davon ist ja dieser Mike Walz von
seinem Posten als Sicherheitsberater enthoben worden.
Der wird dann irgendwie so jetzt zur UN gehen und so weiter.
Also es ist vollkommen absurd.
Seine Rolle übernimmt jetzt glaube
ich auch noch der Hexe sogar glaube ich sogar selber noch. Also es ist.
Ja, und er soll aber wohl auch nicht zu den Schlimmsten gehört haben,
sondern eher noch, also sozusagen, der, der.
Der Schlimmste war der Hexess. Der Mike Reitz hat ja sozusagen den Chat nur
aufgesetzt und der war dafür zuständig, dass dieser Atlantic Reporter da reinkam,
wodurch diese ganze Geschichte ja überhaupt erst aufgeflogen ist.
Aber wer wirklich die schmutzigen Details da reingeworfen hat, das war ja der Hexess.
Und wie sich später herausgestellt hat, hat er das ja nicht nur in diesem Group
Chat gemacht mit diesem Principal Committee, wo er theoretisch,
abgesehen von dem Journalisten, ja auch alle quasi zum Thema gehören.
Nein, er hatte ja noch einen zweiten Group Chat, wo er dieselbe Information
reingeworfen hat mit seiner Frau und seinem Bruder.
Aber zumindest, also Mike Waltz war halt immer schon eher auf der Seite der Ukraine.
Er war eigentlich eher ein Ukraine-Fan während Hexas eigentlich.
Das war auch Marco Rubio, aber seitdem die halt unter Trumps Ägide sind,
singen sie halt das Lied vom Trump.
Und deswegen hilft das halt auch alles relativ wenig.
Naja, soviel zu dem Chaos rund um Peak Hexes,
aber das viel größere Chaos ist ja eigentlich diese sogenannten Friedensverhandlungen,
die Trump führen möchte mit Russland und wie sich das in den letzten Wochen alles entwickelt hat.
Und also muss man das mal wissen, wir hatten ja ursprünglich hier auch diesen
Kellogg erwähnt, der ja mal als Ukrainer Beauftragter auserwählt wurde und der
ja eigentlich auch mal so ein bisschen pro Ukraine war. Das klang ja alles ganz nett.
Problem ist nur, dass er in seiner Rolle überhaupt nicht ernst genommen wird,
sondern stattdessen wurde ja diese gesamte weitere sogenannte Friedensverhandlung
mit den Russen dann übernommen von dem Golf-Buddy von Trump,
auch so ein Real-Estate-Mensch,
Witkoff.
Der von Diplomatie und Russland und der Ukraine ganz offensichtlich nicht auch
nur den Hauch eines Anflugs einer Ahnung hat.
Also es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie inkompetent diese Person ist.
Der soll aber sozusagen der Verhandlungsführer sein für den Nahen Osten und
wurde dann quasi auch als Kontaktmensch für Putin auserkoren,
war jetzt auch schon x-mal in Moskau und lässt sich da von ihm irgendwelche Geschichten erzählen,
geht danach in die Medien und
redet sozusagen die Putin-Propaganda eins zu eins in alle Mikrofone rein.
Völlig absurd. Der Typ war irgendwie bei Fox News, hat da irgendwie ein Interview
gegeben und war noch nicht mal in der Lage.
Also er forderte zwar, dass irgendwie die Ukraine dann irgendwie ihr Land aufgeben
sollte und die Russen würden dann einfach die vier teilweise besetzten Gebiete,
also es war halt konkret natürlich von Kherson, Saborizhia,
Donetsk und Luhanski die Rede, also das, was ja die Russen auch sozusagen für
sich in Anspruch nehmen, was ja angeblich schon Russland sei.
Ja, diese Gebiete hat er zwar erwähnt, konnte aber noch nicht mal die Namen richtig aufzählen.
Also man merkte richtig literally, wie er überhaupt gar keine Ahnung hat von
der Situation oder auch nur von der geografischen Realität der Ukraine.
Ja, und so läuft dieses Spiel die ganze Zeit.
Das heißt, Trump hat im Wesentlichen durch seine Schergen die ganze Zeit so
getan, als wäre er jetzt in irgendeiner Form in Friedensverhandlungen,
die aber ausschließlich zwischen ihm und Putin geführt werden sollen.
Das Problem ist nur, dass Putin irgendwie nicht so richtig mitspielt.
Trump gibt öffentlich bekannt,
dass er ja sozusagen von Russland, ja Russland muss eigentlich gar nichts machen,
alle Gebiete, die jetzt besetzt sind, sollen russisch bleiben,
plus halt diese vier Gebiete sollen auch noch an Russland fallen.
Also im Wesentlichen ist sein Vorschlag für Friedensverhandlungen so.
Dass was Putin die ganze Zeit seit Monaten irgendwie sagt, was sein soll.
Das sind sozusagen die Bedingungen. Und die Ukraine soll ja einfach mal ihr
Land abgeben, dafür aber auch nicht in die NATO kommen und keine Sicherheitsgarantien bekommt.
Also sozusagen alles für Russland, nichts für die Ukraine. Völlig absurd.
So ging das die ganze Zeit hin und her. Es gab Treffen in Saudi-Arabien und
dann eben auch diese Besuche in Russland selber und die ganze Zeit taten sie
so, als würden sie irgendwas tun.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie du das gesehen hast, aber für mich war einfach die ganze
Zeit klar, also mich hat das ehrlich gesagt noch nicht mal besonderlich beunruhigt, weil.
Und es ist so offensichtlich und so klar, dass nichts von dem,
was dort diskutiert wurde, für die Ukraine auch nur ansatzweise in Frage gekommen wäre.
Also die hätten sich auf den Kopf stellen können.
Es gibt da einfach keinen Leverage, die die USA hat, um die Ukraine dazu zu
bringen, auch nur irgendetwas davon zu akzeptieren.
Ja, vor allen Dingen nicht, wenn Europa nicht mitzieht.
Genau, was sie natürlich auch nicht gemacht haben.
Aber was, ich meine,
ich kenne halt ein paar Amerikaner so und durfte halt bei den einen oder anderen
Partys dabei sein und da bekommt man halt schon auch Einblicke einfach,
wie das eigentlich funktioniert oder wie das professionell funktionieren sollte
oder bisher funktioniert hat.
Wenn du jetzt Politiker bist beispielsweise und solche Entscheidungen betrifft.
Natürlich kannst du nicht alles wissen und die USA ist ja global präsent so
und es gibt so viele Regionen.
Insofern lass dich jetzt dem Wittkopf nicht an, dass er die Namen nicht parat
hatte, sondern er war schlecht vorbereitet.
Das ist der Punkt. Das Ganze ist halt Teamplay. hey, du hast halt deine Experten.
Die sich eben bestens auskennen.
Und wenn du jetzt in so ein Interview reingehst oder irgendwelche Entscheidungen
triffst, redest du halt mit Leuten, die sich auskennen und die Informationen sind da.
Du musst nur dann die entsprechend auch verdichten und komprimieren,
weil einfach zu viele Informationen da sind. Und dazu brauchst du einfach ein
eingespieltes Team, das dich unterstützt.
Das ist eigentlich universell. Aber diese Leute sind halt einfach keine Teamplayer
und meinen, alles besser zu wissen, statt halt die Leute zu fragen,
die sich auskennen und sich professionell vorbereiten zu lassen.
Und da ist eben aber auch, dass halt viele der Profis, die sich einfach auskennen,
sagen, auch mit diesen Leuten, so wie die sich gebären, habe ich keinen Bock, mich abzugeben.
Die dann teilweise auch aus, ja, das sind halt Leute, die einfach komplett unfähig
sind, Führungspositionen zu bekleiden und so.
Führungspositionen zu bekleiden oder Manager zu sein, heißt jetzt nicht unbedingt,
dass man sich jetzt fachlich auskennen muss, sondern man ist jemand,
der Informationsflüsse.
Lenkt und sich eben schlau macht und dann mit Hilfe der Unterstützung und der
Information, die man hat, dann die bestmöglichen Entscheidungen trifft.
Und ja, dass er da die Provinz nicht aufzählen konnte und auch nicht,
ja, und sich dabei hatte ertappen lassen auch noch, das ist einfach,
ja, die Leute gehören da einfach nicht hin.
Die haben nicht die notwendige, nicht Reife oder Führungsqualität,
um irgendwie professionell arbeiten zu können in so einem komplizierten Umfeld.
So kann man das, glaube ich, einfach nur zusammenfassen und,
kriegen sie auch so leicht jetzt nicht, weil wie gesagt, einfach ganz viele
der Profis sagen einfach, alle erfahrene Leute, ich habe meine Zeit um,
ich muss mir das nicht antun, ich muss mir diese Leute nicht antun.
Ist natürlich gefährlich und tragisch auch, aber ja, im Moment scheint mir die,
Haltung zu sein, wir treten jetzt einfach mal alle zurück und gucken uns an,
wie die das gegen die Wand fahren und dann schauen wir mal,
wie wir das wieder gerettet kriegen oder auch nicht.
Kann sogar die richtige Strategie sein.
Scheitern werden sie auf jeden Fall.
Aber ich kann auch niemanden verdenken, der sich jetzt teilweise 20,
30 oder 40 Jahre den Hintern aufgerissen hat und da sind viele Leute dabei, die,
ernsthaft und gebildet also viele von denen schreiben jetzt Bücher,
über ihre Zeit und einige davon waren jetzt auch an Hochschulen aktiv und haben
dann unterrichtet, was sie gelernt haben aber selbst das,
da haben sie jetzt keinen Bock mehr drauf in dem teilweise aktuellen Umfeld
und wo überall gekürzt wird.
Also im Moment erstmal ein krasser Niedergang an Institutionen und institutioneller Professionalität,
die man beobachten kann.
Und das geht so weit wie wirklich...
Das ist absolute Anfängerfehler, auch mit den Zöllen, wenn wir jetzt gleich,
ich weiß nicht, ob wir schon bei den Zöllen sind.
Aber… Genau, da kommen wir noch zu, es gibt genug Unprofessionalität zu berichten,
aber jetzt ging es ja erstmal darum, was tut Trump?
Ich meine, wir hatten ja seine Ankündigung, nicht, dass irgendjemand,
der sie noch halbwegs alle beisammen hat, auch nur ansatzweise dem irgendein
Glauben hat schenken können, seine Ankündigung mit, er würde innerhalb von 24
Stunden diesen Krieg beenden. Ja, also totaler Quatsch.
Die ersten 24 Stunden waren sowieso erstmal Golf spielen.
Von daher kann das nichts werden. Aber halt auch in einer Woche und einem Monat
ist das nichts zu machen.
Friedensverhandlungen eines solch großen Konflikts sind in der Regel in der
Weltgeschichte Dinge, die irgendwie auch mal ein oder zwei Jahre dauern können.
Und dann ist es schon schnell gelaufen und wir sehen ja, wie das mit den Friedensverhandlungen
im Nahen Osten so funktioniert.
Also das war natürlich eh alles Unsinn.
Nichtsdestotrotz, Trump halt einfach losmarschiert und groß rumposaunt und ich
glaube, man muss sich auch so ein bisschen davon trennen, dass Trump irgendwie
einen großen Plan hat. Der hat keinen Plan.
Der denkt nicht bis zum Abend,
sondern alles ist irgendwie impulsiv und er hat so ein paar ganz grundlegende
Überzeugungen, wie zum Beispiel, dass Zöllel eine ganz tolle Idee sind und vor
allem ist er auch irgendwie der Überzeugung, dass so seine ganzen Macho-Mafia-Buddies,
die er so rund um die Welt so ausgemacht hat,
zu denen er so aufblickt, wie Putin und Xi und so weiter.
Oder hier Kim Jong-un und all diese ganzen Katastrophen,
dass er irgendwie da quasi mitspielt, weil er ist ja jetzt irgendwie Trump und
er ist die USA und ich glaube, der glaubt auch mittlerweile,
dass er der Auserwählte ist, weil sein Kult, den er da anzeugt hat bei den Leuten halt einfach,
die ihn zu so einer Art Gott-Messias ausgerufen haben.
Ich glaube, der glaubt das mittlerweile auch. Und jetzt will er eigentlich auch
noch einen Nobelpreis haben, weil er hat ja Obama auch bekommen.
Und wie kriegt man den ja, indem man hier irgendwie Frieden schafft.
Deswegen wird jetzt hier mal Frieden gemacht.
Und seine Vorstellung von Frieden ist, naja, USA und Russland,
die beiden Großen, die reden da mal so untereinander.
Komm, wir klären das mal hier unter uns. Und dann werden schon alle unterschreiben
und dann passt das schon.
Das ist im Wesentlichen das, was hier so passiert ist. Und dann schickt er halt
so Vögel wie diesen Wittkopf, die von Tuten und Blasen keine Ahnung haben und
von Diplomatie und diesem Konflikt schon gar nicht.
Die schickt er dann irgendwie vor, um das irgendwie zu regeln und treffen dann
halt auf so Hardcore-Diplomatie-Haie wie irgendwie diesen Lavrov.
Der seit 30 Jahren Außenminister ist, ich weiß nicht, ob es schon wirklich 30
Jahre, mindestens 20 Jahre auf jeden Fall seit Putin da ist,
der mit allen Wassern gewaschen ist, der die Welt kennt.
Und dann kommt dann irgendein Real Estate Manager, der keine Ahnung hat und
der soll ihm dann irgendwie irgendein Zugeständnis abbringen.
Das funktioniert so nicht.
So, mit anderen Worten, Trump will eigentlich im Wesentlichen das Thema einfach nur abräumen.
Der will einfach, dass das Thema nicht mehr da ist, damit er sich wieder um
Grönland kümmern kann oder irgendeinen Scheiß und unterschätzt einfach maßlos seinen Einfluss.
Und wie wir ja eben schon gehört haben, trotzdem war dieser Militärsupport der USA nie wirklich weg.
Das lief eigentlich im Wesentlichen alles irgendwie so weiter,
wie es halt schon vereinbart war, abgesehen eben von diesem Kurzschluss,
den da Hexeth gehabt hat.
Aber mittlerweile trifft halt Trump auch hier die Realität und man merkt halt,
wie er so in seinen Äußerungen zunehmendem Maße jetzt so, ja,
irgendwie macht Russland ja gar nichts.
Hier war ja Waffenstillstand angesagt, die haben es ja angeboten.
Ukraine hat da auch mitgespielt.
Das fand ich ja übrigens auch eine diplomatisch sehr feine Nummer.
Es war ja eh klar, dass so ein Waffenstillstand in dem Sinne nie wirklich eingehalten
werden würde von den Russen.
Das weiß halt auch Zelensky. Er redet ja seit drei Jahren von nichts anderem,
als dass die Russen sich nie an irgendwas halten.
Deswegen hat er das halt auch, glaube ich, zu keinem Zeitpunkt auch nur ansatzweise
geglaubt. Und trotzdem war diese ganze Auseinandersetzung im Oval Office und
so weiter, die halt so öffentlich geführt wurde, war ja dann immer so,
ja nee, wir brauchen ja einen Waffenstillstand.
Das ist ja auch so dieses BSW-Argument und AfD und so weiter.
Also alle Leute, die überhaupt gar kein Interesse daran haben,
der Ukraine wirklich zu helfen, labern die ganze Zeit irgendwas von Waffenstillstand,
als wäre ein Waffenstillstand halt jetzt irgendwie Frieden. Aber Waffenschildstein ist kein Frieden.
Waffenschildstein ist Waffenschildstein, wenn es überhaupt diesen Namen verdient.
Trotzdem hat sich aber Selenskyj dann gedacht, okay, ihr wollt jetzt Waffenstillstand
haben, wir machen Waffenstillstand.
Und dieses einseitig ausgerufene Waffenstillstandsding, was dann so ein,
zwei Wochen halten sollte,
das hat die Ukraine insofern mitgespielt, als dass sie gesagt haben,
wir halten uns jetzt daran, wir greifen jetzt keine Ölindustrien an.
Weil das war so eine Forderung von den USA. Warum auch immer.
Gut, in der Zwischenzeit haben sie andere Fabriken angegriffen.
Es gab genug, wo sie ihre Aufmerksamkeit drauf lenken konnten.
Die anderen waren sowieso weitgehend erstmal damit beschäftigt,
also die ganzen Ölstandorte waren damit beschäftigt, auszubrennen und repariert
zu werden. Da musste man jetzt eh gerade nichts Neues draufwerfen.
Von daher haben sie sich halt so rein formell an diese Regelungen dran gehalten
und dann halt immer gefragt, was ist denn jetzt hier mit Putin,
wo bleibt denn der Waffenstillstand? Kam er halt nicht.
Naja, und dann ist das halt auch irgendwann mal in der Öffentlichkeit so weit
durchgedrungen, dass auch Trump einsehen musste, dass halt diese ganze Strategie,
wenn man diesen Namen überhaupt verwenden darf, halt hinten und vorne nicht funktioniert.
Und interessanterweise, ich will jetzt mal nicht sagen, da ist jetzt irgendwas
gekippt, aber es sind immer so kurzfristige Bewegungen.
Das kann auch morgen schon wieder anders sein. aber man hat ja gesehen Trump
hat sich ja dann alleine mit Zelensky getroffen bei dieser Papstbeerdigung und
hatten ja dann dieses Gespräch, von dem diese beeindruckenden Bilder geschossen wurden,
ob jetzt dieses Gespräch selber relevant war oder nicht,
es war so ein Zeichen für eine geänderte Vorgehensweise ja, also auf einmal waren sie jetzt.
Bisschen am Ende mit dieser Erzählung, wie böse doch die Ukraine ist und die
Ukraine hätte ja den Krieg angefangen und sich nie bedankt und all dieser Quatsch,
den sie da halt im Oval Office abgelassen haben und danach.
Und auf einmal kippte das halt um mit, oh der böse Putin, der hält sich aber
hier gar nicht daran, was wir wollen.
So und ich muss sagen, ich gewinne in zunehmendem Maße den Eindruck,
dass Zelensky mehr ist als nur ein Glücksfall für die Ukraine.
Tatsächlich hat er einfach in dieser Zeit und vielleicht lag ihm das schon immer,
aber ich denke mal ist auch ein großer Lernprozess hier natürlich, der stattgefunden hat.
Er ist wirklich langsam so ein bisschen der Superdiplomat, weil wie er das jetzt
gesteuert hat von, er ist jetzt der Nummer 1 Feind von Trump und J.D.
Vance und wird irgendwie als erster Politiker der Welt im Oval Office angeschrien
zu Trump und Zelensky unterhalten sich bei der Papstbeerdigung mal so ganz privat, aber unter Kameras.
Trump so nach vorne geneigt, als würde er wirklich noch Interesse haben.
Das ist schon ein großer Wurf. Und vor allem,
und da kommen wir dann sozusagen schon zu so einem Zwischenpunkt,
es ging ja die ganze Zeit um diesen sogenannten Rohstoff-Deal.
Das war ja so ein bisschen der Auslöser. Deswegen war Selinski eigentlich nach Washington gefahren,
um dann noch vor dieser Unterzeichnung halt bloßgestellt zu werden und dann
kurzfristig abzureißen, sodass halt dann das vorgelegte Vertragsdokument ja
nicht unterschrieben wurde.
Mittlerweile gab es weitere Verhandlungen,
Hinter den Kulissen. Und jetzt wurde dieser Deal unterschrieben.
Und ich meine, zum einen hatte die Ukraine eine amerikanische Anwaltsfirma,
eine von den großen, die dann so 500 bis 1000 Anwälte haben,
damit beauftragt, sie zu vertreten und den Vertrag mit auszuarbeiten.
Die großen Bedenken, die sie ins Feld geführt waren, waren, dass bestimmte Klauseln,
die die USA ursprünglich haben wollten, einen EU-Beitritt erschwert hätten.
Weil du kannst nicht, wenn du EU-Member bist, kannst du nicht sagen.
Okay und dieser Staat hat aber jetzt Vorrang, also die USA haben jetzt Vorrangsrecht
bei hier bestimmte Firmen zu gründen oder hier Rohstoffe abzubauen.
Und das geht halt nicht, das verstößt halt gegen EU-Recht.
Und deswegen haben die das halt dann, also aus dem Punkt haben sie dann wohl
erfolgreich ausräumen können und jetzt eigentlich eine Variante von einem 50-50-Deal.
Keiner hat, sagen die Mehrheit, keiner hat einen Golden Share und das ist im
Grunde genommen ein Fonds.
Und es wird auch nichts von den bisherigen Unterstützungen angerechnet und so.
Also eigentlich ein akzeptabler Deal aus Sicht der Ukraine, muss man sagen.
Und zu diesem, wie Selenskyj sich verhalten hat, vielleicht hat ihm jemand einfach nur gesagt,
komm Trump ist ein Reality-TV-Star und irgendwann wird in seiner Welt diese
Putin-Nummer alt werden.
So, die Ratings gehen runter und jetzt muss halt irgendwie wieder,
ja, neue Staffel ja, mit ähm.
Muss halt jetzt unter neuen Vorzeichen geführt werden.
Er hat halt gemerkt, dass das irgendwie nicht gut ankommt mit dem Ukraine-Bashing
und dass halt für bessere Ratings er jetzt vielleicht besser umschwenkt.
So, das ist jetzt auch eine These und Selenskyj hat das halt geahnt und gehofft
und eben die ganze Zeit ein bisschen auf Zeit gespielt und dann den richtigen
Zeitpunkt abgewartet und bis dann,
das Diktat der Einschalt- und Zustimmungsquoten eine Korrektur erfordert,
die dann zu seinen Gunsten oder
zu Gunsten Ukraine ausfällt und das Kalkül scheint aufgegangen zu sein.
Ja, sieht so aus. Es ist ihm gelungen, quasi,
trotz dieser ganzen Wirren den Support der USA nicht nur zu erhalten,
sondern es gibt jetzt eben auch, hatten wir vorhin ja schon erwähnt,
tatsächlich die ersten neun Militärunterstützungsbeschlüsse.
Alles noch keine nennenswerten Summen. Ich meine, wir reden von 50 Millionen
hier, 300 Millionen da, das ist sozusagen,
Total Peanuts, aber da geht es dann auch erstmal um den Move als solchen und
der findet halt statt und wird sicherlich auch auf Interesse stoßen.
Und ja, dieser Deal, der Rohstoffdeal, ich meine,
so wird der immer jetzt genannt, weil Trump den immer so genannt hat,
aber was es halt eigentlich ist, ist halt ein Investmentfonds zum Wiederaufbau der Ukraine, der halt.
Exploitation von Natural Resources, also Minentätigkeit, Ausgrabung von was
auch immer unter der Erde ist in der Ukraine und was man verwenden kann, um da Geld reinzutun.
Also im Wesentlichen ist es erstmal ein Investmentfond, das heißt amerikanische
Unternehmen haben die Möglichkeit dort hinein zu investieren,
um zu finanzieren, dass das überhaupt alles gemacht wird.
Gewinne fließen da rein und die Ukraine gibt auch keine Kontrolle ab.
Also die Fifty-Fifty-Regelung bezieht sich auf, was der Pfund tut,
aber das hat auch gar keine Auswirkungen darauf auf Staatsbetriebe,
die gehören dann nicht irgendwie den USA oder so, sondern es bleibt alles in
der Hand der Ukraine und die Ukraine definiert auch, was abgebaut wird,
wo abgebaut wird, was nicht abgebaut wird.
Und bestehende Minen und Ölfelder und Gasfelder und so fallen nicht darunter.
Also das ist wahrscheinlich kein entscheidendes Instrument.
Es ist jetzt politisch natürlich ein Gewinn, weil es dazu kam und damit quasi
die USA auch das erste Mal offiziell so eine Art wirtschaftliches Standbein
hat in diesem ganzen Konflikt.
Ja, und die Russen mögen es nicht, weil die Russen natürlich jetzt glauben,
dass in den besetzten Gebieten halt jetzt Rohstoffe sind,
die die USA jetzt haben möchte und deswegen halt die Ukraine so sehr unterstützen
wird aufgrund dieses Deals,
weil eben ja Rohstoffe halt.
Also was halt auch nicht wirklich banal ist, aber das ist das,
was im russischen Staatsfernsehen jetzt die Pandits dort gerade von sich geben.
Ja, so zum Abschluss müssen wir natürlich jetzt nochmal diese Auswirkungen von
Trumps merkwürdiger Zollpolitik diskutieren im Zusammenhang mit diesem Konflikt.
Das hängt natürlich nicht im eigentlichen Sinne zusammen, aber es führt ja dazu,
dass die Welt sich insgesamt neu formiert.
Und das stellt natürlich dann auch gleich die Frage auf, wo landet die Ukraine
und der Ukraine-Konflikt in dieser sich neu aufstellenden Machtgeschichte.
Und was passiert ist, habt ihr ja alle mitbekommen.
Trump ist ja irgendwie seit den 80er Jahren völlig überzeugt davon,
dass Tarife, ich sag mal Tarife, weil die Amerikaner Terris sagen,
dass Zölle irgendwie eine tolle Idee sind, um in irgendeiner Form...
Dinge zu bewirken, ja, ich glaube Trump sieht das im Wesentlichen so als Machtinstrument
und er möchte halt gerne mit seiner Macht rumwedeln und alle zu irgendwas zwingen,
das Ding ist nur, er hat halt überhaupt gar keinen klaren Plan,
worauf es eigentlich hinauslaufen soll, also er träumt immer von irgendwelchen Deals,
die dann sozusagen den USA,
was weiß ich, noch mehr Vorrechte einräumen, als sie ohnehin schon haben.
Und offensichtlich bewirkt er das Gegenteil, nachdem er halt irgendwie in diesem absurden.
Treffen oder Veröffentlichung dieser Rede da im Garten des Weißen Hauses diese
alberne Tabelle hochgehalten hat, die sie offensichtlich mit JGPT zusammengestellt haben,
weil es sich irgendwie rausgestellt hat, dass die Liste der Länder irgendwie
so sich so ein bisschen an Top-Level-Domains orientieren und dabei ja dann auch
irgendwie so eine ausschließlich von Pinguinen bewohnte Insel dann auch noch
mit Zöllen belegt wurde, wo es überhaupt gar keinen Handel gibt.
Die Liste der Länder in sich war absurd und die Zahlen, die dahinter standen,
waren noch absurder und auch noch absurd war die Länder, die offensichtlich
gestrichen worden sind von Hand,
so wie Russland und Belarus,
aber die Ukraine stand drauf auf der Liste.
Es war in sich komplett absurd und es wurden auch Zölle plötzlich eingeführt
oder vorgeschlagen gegenüber Ländern, wo die USA einen,
Außenhandelsüberschuss hat mit denen, was irgendwie überhaupt keinen Sinn macht,
da hätte also nach derselben Logik, hätte dann das andere Land eigentlich jetzt
Zölle gegen die USA erheben müssen,
um das auszubalancieren, ja, weil, ich meine, wenn das die Logik ist,
dass du es ausgeglichen haben willst, dann kannst du ja auch keine Überschüsse
haben, ja, dann musst du...
Also allein schon der Ansatz, dass ein Handelsdefizit an sich in irgendeiner
Form eine Ungerechtigkeit ausdrückt, ist sowas von absurd, weil es ja nichts anderes sagt als...
Ich kaufe mehr von dir, als du von mir. Und jeder, der mal im Supermarkt war,
weiß, dass wir generell im Supermarkt mehr kaufen, als der Supermarkt von uns kauft.
Das heißt zwar Handelsdefizit, aber das Wort Defizit ist in dem Zusammenhang
ein rein mathematischer Begriff und drückt keinen volkswirtschaftlichen Zustand
aus, der in irgendeiner Form bedenklich wäre.
Weil am Ende bedeutet das ja eigentlich nur, Die USA ist reich genug,
um sich sozusagen überall was kaufen zu können und muss es selber nicht herstellen.
Und das ist ja eigentlich genau das, was den nominellen Reichtum der USA ausmacht.
Und genau das stört dann irgendwie Trump. Also es schmerzt einfach irgendwo
an verschiedenen Stellen im Hirn, wenn man nur darüber nachdenkt,
was da eigentlich an die Wand gemalt wurde.
Aber das Ergebnis ist natürlich, dass halt dadurch alle Handelsrouten komplett
explodieren und insbesondere ging es halt dann immer irgendwie um China,
weil am Ende sind ja dann alle Zölle einfach pauschal mal wieder auf 10 Prozent runtergesetzt worden.
Und das Ganze ist jetzt auch nochmal für drei Monate ausgesetzt worden. Außer China.
Und in China haben sie sich dann hoch eskadiert auf was weiß ich, wo sind wir jetzt?
125 oder 175 Prozent Zölle auf alle Waren.
Ja, also 100 absurd Prozent mit Ausnahme außer iPhones.
Ja, Zölle auf alles außer iPhones so ungefähr.
Ja, also. Weil da würden nämlich die Amerikaner, da würden die alle total durchdrehen,
wenn auf einmal die iPhones teurer werden.
Was ich nicht wusste, iPhones haben glaube ich über 50% Marktanteil in den USA.
Oder 60 oder so. Das heißt, ohne iPhones hier würden die Leute durchdrehen.
Ohne neue iPhones. oder wenn die plötzlich 500 oder 1000 Dollar mehr kosten.
So, dann das, ja, also das Ganze eine komplett hirnrissige Aktion,
völlig undurchdacht, ähm,
Und dieses ganze Vor- und Zurück- und Hin- und Her- an sich zu massiven Problemen
geführt und verhindert auch,
dass irgendwelche der Vorteile, die die Zölle mit sich bringen können, eintritt.
Weil entweder du kannst halt deinen
Staatshaushalt aufbessern und eine Menge Geld einnehmen oder du kannst Importe
reduzieren aus bestimmten Ländern dann durch diese Zölle.
Und gut, das allein für sich ist jetzt kein Ziel, also Importe zu reduzieren.
An sich ist ja nichts Gutes, da fehlt es halt an den Importen.
Aber theoretisch kannst du dann ja Investitionen und Produktionen im Inland stimulieren.
Aber kein Mensch baut irgendeine Produktion im Inland auf unter diesen Bedingungen.
Wo von einer Woche zur anderen sich im Moment alles ändern kann.
Du aber mindestens fünf Jahre brauchst, um Produktion auszubauen und dann wahrscheinlich
fünf bis zehn Jahre unter den Bedingungen operieren musst,
damit sich das Ganze rentiert.
Das heißt, im Moment investiert niemand im Inland und gleichzeitig ist aber speziell aus China,
mit den absurden Zöllen gehen die Importe massiv runter.
Und ich verfolge das ja irgendwie auch, also da gibt es jetzt tägliche Updates
irgendwie in diesem Shipping-Channel What's going on with Shipping.
Genau, was an den Häfen sich tut.
Genau. Ja, und das ist sehr interessant, also ich hatte mir halt angeguckt,
okay, wie viel Prozent vom Bruttoinlandsprodukt so machen jetzt jeweils in den
USA und in China und in Europa und so,
wie hoch ist der Anteil am Bruttoinlandsprodukt und dann am Handel?
Aber entscheidend ist eigentlich der Anteil am Bruttoinlandsprodukt.
Wenn man sich da die Zahlen anguckt, sogar festhalten, die würden das alle überleben.
Also alle Parteien und speziell China und so, das sind halt niedrige einstellige
Prozentzahlen vom Bruttoinlandsprodukt, die jetzt der Handel mit den USA ausmacht.
Aber so beim Handelsvolumen und in einzelnen Branchen und so sieht es halt ganz anders aus.
In Los Angeles kommen 60 Prozent der Waren, die dort im Hafen angelandet werden,
kommen aus China. Ja, so.
Das heißt, dass dann, und die gehen halt auch nicht auf Null runter,
das kann man jetzt sehen, dass es in vielen Fällen immer noch günstiger 150
Prozent oder 200 Prozent Zölle zu zahlen,
als es gar nicht zu haben.
Oder es im Inland zu produzieren, weil das halt dann auch Anlaufkosten und Zeit mit sich bringt und so.
Also es ist halt oft einfach alternativlos.
Das heißt, deswegen kommt halt ein Teil trotzdem.
Aber es ist natürlich ein extremer Rückgang zu beobachten.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass es jetzt völlig zum Erliegen gekommen ist,
auch wegen gewisser Ausnahmen.
Die andere Sache, was passiert ist, Viele Leute haben halt Sachen schon produzieren
lassen und das Geld schon ausgegeben und auch die Frachtgebühren schon bezahlt.
Das heißt, was die halt machen ist, die lassen es erstmal reinkommen und können
es dann bis zu sieben Tage im Hafen lassen oder können es halt dann erstmal
in einem Zollfreihafen einlagern,
wo es quasi nicht importiert ist, sondern dort nur lagert.
Und dann entweder wieder exportiert werden kann oder dann irgendwann aus diesem
Zollfreihafen importiert werden kann.
Und erst dann wird der Zoll fällig, sodass viele dann darauf hoffen auch und
erst mal Zeugs einlagern, dass sich das dann ändert und dass sie es dann aus den Lagern rausholen,
wenn Trump weg ist oder zur Vernunft gekommen ist oder zur Vernunft geprügelt
worden ist von den Wählern.
Allerdings ist diese Lagerkapazität halt auch begrenzt und die sind halt voll
und das kostet halt auch Geld. Das heißt, es ist alles so limitiert.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, es ist jetzt nicht das Ende der Welt im Moment gerade,
wie es von vielen propagiert wird.
Aber es ist halt schon heftiger Einschnitt für ganz viele Branchen und wird
sicherlich auch die Arbeitslosigkeit in die Höhe treiben.
Auch die Trucker, die überwiegend hier in den USA Trump-Wähler sind wohl.
Angeblich 80 oder 90 Prozent der aller LKW-Fahrer hier sind Trump-Fans.
Und die haben jetzt teilweise erheblich mit Auftragsrückgängen zu kämpfen in bestimmten Gegenden.
Und ich muss sagen, die Trucker hier sind auch, also die fahren hier normalerweise mit 120 kmh,
so 80 Meilen und so oft auf dem Highway und überholen regelmäßig Pkw.
Und ich weiß nicht, ich habe noch nicht geguckt, wie das eigentlich ist mit
den Höchstgeschwindigkeiten.
Ist wahrscheinlich von Staat zu Staat wieder anders, aber auf jeden Fall,
ja, also die sind auch nicht, auch gerade nicht alle nicht besonders happy,
so wie ja auch andere Teile der Trump-Wählerschaft.
Aber noch sind die Läden voll, kann ich aus, also heute am 7.
Mai kann ich, also es gibt keine Knappheit an irgendwas, es gibt alles irgendwie,
es gibt Klopapier, es gibt billigen China-Kram, es gibt Textilien und so,
aber ich habe gehört, die Sommerkollektion ist in Gefahr.
Ja, vor allem es gibt ja noch einen Delay in dieser ganzen Sache.
Und es gibt halt diese Verzögerungsstrategien, die du ja schon genannt hast,
aber es ist ja auch so, ein Schiff fährt halt in China irgendwie los und das
ist dann auch erstmal eine Weile unterwegs.
Also auch wenn es jetzt nach Los Angeles jetzt nicht einmal um die ganzen Planeten
herumfahren muss, aber das ist schon mal Strecke.
Und das muss dann erstmal ankommen. Und bis dass dann wirklich die bestehenden
Lager, Restbestände und so weiter aufgebraucht sind in bestimmten Produktkategorien,
vergeht ohnehin etwas Zeit.
Also es ist ja jetzt nicht alles just in time, was irgendwie im Supermarkt liegt.
Trotzdem, der Punkt wird kommen und der wird in den nächsten Wochen kommen.
Für manche Produkte früher, für manche Produkte später.
Aber was es ja jetzt vor allem ausgelöst hat, ist halt diese Unsicherheit.
Man weiß halt nicht, was ist. Jetzt sind die Zölle ausgesetzt,
das heißt sie kommen aber auch oder vielleicht kommen sie auch nicht und so weiter.
Und wenn halt irgendwie die Finanzwelt und die Wirtschaftswelt irgendwas nicht
leiden kann, dann ist es Unsicherheit.
Es ist sozusagen das Undefinierte, was den eigentlichen Schaden macht,
ist gar nicht so sehr die Zölle selbst, sondern es ist einfach nur,
man weiß überhaupt nicht, worauf man sich einstellen soll und wenn man nicht
weiß, worauf man sich einstellen soll,
dann werden halt auch keine Beschlüsse gefasst, da wird nichts investiert,
dann werden keine Leute eingestellt, da werden Projekte erstmal beendet und
da laufen dann halt Dinge aus und wenn halt Lieferketten in Gefahr sind.
Dann guckt man halt mal lieber ob man nicht die Lieferketten von woanders bekommen kann.
Da gibt es natürlich jetzt auch was China betrifft China hat natürlich auch
ein Interesse daran seine Sachen zu verkaufen,
die können es vielleicht schlucken und die wollen es natürlich auch schlucken,
dieses ganze Elend aber haben wollen sie es eigentlich nicht und deswegen wird
jetzt auch sehr viel über andere Länder reexportiert über Malaysia,
Korea und so weiter, muss man mal schauen wie gut das funktioniert oder welchen
großen Anteil das hat teilweise kommt ja durchaus noch was durch aber über kurz
oder lang werden sich natürlich alle überlegen okay,
wenn die USA jetzt überall einen Stock,
reinschmeißen, dann müssen wir halt gucken, wie wir das Ganze ohne die USA lösen können,
und das ist jetzt eigentlich auch das, was passiert und ich will mich jetzt
auch nicht so sehr auf diese Zölle als solche festmachen weil das ist ja jetzt
erstmal nur ein Phänomen das ist sozusagen diese Zölle und dieses Verhalten gegenüber der Ukraine.
Das sind glaube ich so die beiden Ereignisse und die großen Fehler dieser Trump-Administration,
die jetzt dazu führen, dass der Rest der Welt, sich speziell Europa.
Das erste Mal,
seit 80 Jahren neu aufstellt. Man verliert einfach das Vertrauen in die USA.
Und selbst wenn man denkt, dass Trump nur eine Eintagsfliege ist oder eine Zweitagsfliege,
weil das gab es ja nun auch schon mal, aber das sagen wir mal,
dass das dann irgendwie wieder weggeht in vier Jahren. Oder vielleicht auch früher.
Selbst wenn man davon ausgeht.
Man weiß ja jetzt nicht, wie das so weitergeht. Weil die Leute sind ja radikalisiert.
Die Leute, die USA ist halt in zwei krasse Lager gespalten,
die sich gegenseitig hassen und wenn halt sowas wie Trump möglich ist,
dann wird halt der next loony of the day auch wieder daherkommen und auch wieder Unsinn reden.
Also bis man das Gefühl hat, dass die USA sich mental wieder gefangen haben,
selbst wenn sie sich wieder gefangen haben, was ja nicht sicher ist,
ob sie sich fangen werden.
Also bis das auch alle wieder glauben und sagen so, okay, alles klar,
das ist jetzt vorbei, das wird noch lange, lange dauern und deswegen stellt
sich jetzt alles neu auf.
Europa stellt sich neu auf, EU stellt sich neu auf und das wäre jetzt vielleicht
nochmal für uns zum Schluss ganz interessant mal zu diskutieren,
was das jetzt für eine Auswirkung hat, speziell auf die Sicherheitsarchitektur.
Weil wirtschaftlich kann man das jetzt glaube ich alles nicht so richtig sagen,
aber es sind ja jetzt quasi neue Allianzen fällig.
EU und UK nähern sich zum Beispiel an, Kanada und die EU nähern sich jetzt an.
Wir hatten vorhin schon auch bei der Militärproduktion diesen Aspekt,
dass man jetzt nicht mehr in den USA kaufen möchte, dass man europäische Produktionen
hochfahren möchte im Rüstungsbereich oder dass man vor allem eine Sicherheitsallianz diskutiert,
die vielleicht ein Unterteil der NATO ist oder vielleicht etabliert sich sogar
neben der NATO nochmal ein neues europäisches Bündnis,
was die NATO dann quasi ablöst, wenn die USA tatsächlich da nicht mehr mitspielen will.
Ja, das Irre ist, ja, Isolationismus wollen sie ja auch nicht wirklich,
sondern sie wollen immer nur das, was gerade nicht ist.
Aber dass Europa jetzt aufrüstet, ist ihnen jetzt auch nicht recht.
Ja, und es ist dasselbe wie, sie möchten gerne im Inland produzieren und möchten gerne Investitionen,
so vor allen Dingen von Japan,
aber dass Japan so viele Autofabriken besitzt, ist ihnen auch nicht recht.
Ja, so, das heißt, sie möchten irgendwie, keine Ahnung, dass die Leute irgendwie
investieren, aber dann die Investitionen dann verschenken oder so.
Also da ist halt keine, nicht richtig Logik dahinter. Und mein Gefühl ist,
dass es da einen Rebound geben wird eher.
Aber Europa, ja, viele andere Länder so wissen jetzt.
Das Vertrauen ist weg und insbesondere ist aber nicht nur das Vertrauen in die
politischen Akteure, jetzt ist der Trump weg,
sondern auch generell, dass die amerikanische Wirtschaft jetzt nicht nur unter den Bedingungen,
sondern unter allgemein schwierigen Rahmenverhältnissen nach diesem Kurswechsel die Kurve kriegt.
Weil vorher war es auch schon alles so ein bisschen prekär,
gerade die Höhe der Auslandsverschuldung mit 120 Prozent des Bruttoinlandprodukts,
aber das kann man verkraften, da kann man auch noch mehr machen,
was du aber nicht willst ist.
Speziell die USA hat natürlich das Problem oder bisher den Vorteil,
dass aufgrund des Dollars als Leitwährung sie eigentlich beliebig viel Geld
drucken können und auch keine Probleme haben, sich so viel Geld zu leihen,
wie sie wollen unter relativ zu relativ günstigen Bedingungen.
Wobei Bedingungen halt zunehmend ungünstiger geworden sind oder werden und Investitionen
jetzt nicht mehr in dem Umfang in die USA fließen,
sondern umgekehrt eher Geld abgezogen wird, obwohl sich das alles auch in Grenzen hält.
Es ist immer schwierig, sich da ein klares Bild zu machen,
weil da wird dann viel behauptet, so nach dem Motto,
ja und Chinesen oder wer auch immer haben jetzt Geld abgezogen und deswegen
gehen die Zinsen jetzt in die Höhe, die die USA bezahlen muss.
Das stimmt alles nur so halb.
Also wenn ich versuche, das dann immer zu verifizieren, stehe ich dann fest,
dass es ganz so eindeutig ist, ist das alles nicht.
Aber bereits jetzt zahlt die USA deutlich höhere Zinsen als Deutschland beispielsweise.
Wenn sie sich Geld leiht.
Deutschland ist auch nur halb so viel verschuldet wie die USA.
Aber ja, die Haushaltsspielräume, das Problem ist, dass halt die USA extrem
verschwenderisch operiert.
Also wenn, ich meine, Musk mit Doge hat es jetzt eher, glaube ich,
noch schlimmer gemacht, aber generell ist hier irgendwie alles super ineffizient und ja,
nichts ist wirklich so richtig haltbar.
Aber trotzdem alt, die Straßen sind zu breit, die Kühlschränke zu groß,
die Lebensmittelpackungen, also es ist halt einfach pervers,
wie viel hier dann einfach in den Müll geht, weil beispielsweise,
also du kannst keine kleinen Packungen kaufen, beziehungsweise kleine Packungen
sind hier so viel überproportional teurer.
Also ein Ei, also sechs Eier ist das kleinste, was du überhaupt kriegst.
Das ist aber bei uns auch so. Sechs Eier.
Ja, ja. Aber die sind dann fast doppelt so teuer wie dann, oder fast genauso
teuer wie ein Zehnerpack.
Und die Preise sind hier so gestaltet, dass du immer das Gefühl hast,
okay, wenn ich jetzt das kleine Paket kaufe, wenn ich nur 10 oder 20 Prozent
mehr ausgebe, habe ich das Doppelte.
Und dann kommt noch,
kauf zwei und du kriegst ein drittes umsonst dazu.
So ist das gestaffelt. Und deswegen, wenn du in den Supermarkt gehst,
du wirst quasi dazu getrieben, einfach zu viel zu kaufen oder mehr zu kaufen,
weil du einfach das Gefühl hast, wenn ich in kleinen Mengen kaufe, es geht gar nicht.
Und das führt halt zu unglaublicher Verschwendung.
Die ganzen Klimaanlagen sind schlecht gewartet, so verbrauchen jede Menge Energie.
Aber Energie ist halt auch billig hier, wobei das Gerücht, von wegen hier in
den USA, wer der Sprit billig trifft, nicht auf alle Bundesstaaten zu.
Es gibt Bundesstaaten, so speziell an der Pazifikküste, wo aktuell der Sprit
fast so teuer ist wie in Deutschland.
Also umgerechnet 1,50 Euro pro Liter, also mit teilweise 5,5 Dollar pro Gallone.
Aber es gibt auch Staaten wie New Mexico, wo du für 2,25 Euro.
Also es gibt zwischen einzelnen Bundesstaaten 100% Preisunterschiede,
als wenn du in Deutschland in einer Stadt 1,50 Euro oder 1 Euro zahlst und in
einer anderen Stadt 2 Euro für den Liter.
Also wie gesagt, viele, viele, viele Probleme.
Die Infrastruktur bröckelt viel schlimmer als bei uns.
Also teilweise sieht das hier aus wie kurz nach der Einheit in der DDR,
so mit kaputten Straßen und bröckelnder Beton und ja, alles ist kaputt.
80 bis 90 Prozent hier, was man sieht, ist irgendwie kaputt,
nicht gewartet, quietscht, klappert.
Leckt, was auch, also schrecklich jetzt, ich klinge jetzt vielleicht wie so
ein völlig überdrehter, ordnungsliebender Deutscher,
aber ja, es ist wirklich die Qualität und alles ist laut, es ist ein unglaublich
lautes Land deswegen, weil alles ist laut, Leute reden laut,
die Apparate sind alle laut und niemand, ja und es gibt keine Sonntagsruhe.
Egal, okay, Du schweifst ein wenig ab.
Aber das Problem ist halt, dass die USA einen Mangel an Selbstbewusstsein hat.
Also nicht im Sinne von selbstbewusst sein, im Sinne von mutig,
sondern sich seiner selbst, seines Status in der Welt nicht bewusst ist.
Ja, und das Problem ist aber physisch. Das Problem ist nicht virtuell,
sondern das Problem ist halt, es manifestiert sich wirklich hart.
Das sind 10% Exzellenz und 90% Entwicklungsland.
So fühlt sich das an.
Ja genau, aber diesen Luxus konnten sie sich bisher halt immer leisten,
weil sie es geschafft haben, die US-Dollar zur Reservewährung der Welt zu machen.
Und dadurch halt auch immer wieder Investitionen bekommen und sich halt vor
allem auch immer wieder billig Geld leihen können und deswegen einfach einen
absurden Schuldenberg aufgehäuft haben.
Und das ist ja auch so eine der Vermutungen gewesen, als es Trump völlig überzogen hat mit Kanada.
Auf einmal war ja Ruhe im Karton.
Von heute auf morgen gab es dann auf einmal überhaupt nichts.
Da ging schon so das Gerücht, dass auch Kanada damit gedroht hat,
seine ganzen Bonds, seine ganzen Staatsbonds zu verkaufen.
Also viele Länder kaufen halt, wenn die Aktien fallen, dann gibt es halt normalerweise
einen entsprechenden Kaufbedarf bei Staatsanleihen in den USA.
Das ist immer so dieser Ping-Pong. Je nachdem, wo man mehr, wenn man also, wenn so eine OS ist am,
Aktienmarkt, so dann kaufen alle Aktien, hurra, jetzt gehen die Kurse hoch,
wir verdienen alle mit und wenn es halt sich mal wieder runterruckelt,
dann verkaufen alle mal ganz schnell,
nehmen ihre Gewinne mit und stecken ihre Kohle in Staatsanleihen,
die dann halt irgendwie festverzins sind auf zwar mit wenig, aber eben sicher.
Und dieses Zolltheater, was Trump losgetreten hat,
hat halt die absurde Situation herbeigeführt, dass halt sowohl der Aktienmarkt
komplett in den Keller gegangen ist, als auch die Staatsanleihen immer teurer
wurden, also sie sozusagen keine Abnehmer gefunden haben. Das ist das,
was du auch vorhin wahrscheinlich meintest.
Das hat sich wieder eingependelt, deswegen ist es nicht so richtig klar zu sagen,
aber es war so ein Zeichen, wo alle sehr nervös geworden sind.
Also wo sehr schnell dann so wahrscheinlich die Finanzindustrie und so weiter
ein paar einflussreiche Leute gekommen sind und gesagt haben,
diese Administration, Leute, sorry, aber jetzt übertreibt ihr es gerade total,
das fahrt ihr jetzt gerade komplett gegen die Wand.
Also man muss da bei den Staatsanleihen zwei Dinge auseinanderhalten.
Einmal, sie werden zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt für einen bestimmten Zeitraum
verkauft mit einem bestimmten festen Satz an Zinsen. Also 1,
5, 10 bis das längste sind 30 Jahre so.
Also es gibt so einen Spread typischerweise zwischen,
die ganz kurzfristigen sind meist ein bisschen teurer und 5 Jahre ist so in
der Regel das günstigste und dann wenn es dann wieder länger wird,
so bei 10, 20 und 30 Jahren, geht dann der Zinssatz wieder ein bisschen in die Höhe.
Das ist der Zinssatz, zu dem die Neuausgabe erfolgt. Also das ist das,
was quasi, wenn der Staat Kredit aufnimmt, was ist der Zinssatz im Kreditvertrag.
Die Dinger, die Papiere selber werden aber auch wiederum gehandelt und zu einem festen Preis.
Am Ende der Zeit kriegst du alles wieder, aber während der Laufzeit, je nachdem,
ob die Zinsen zum Ausgabedatum höher waren oder niedriger, ist dann der aktuelle
Wert der Staatsanleihen zwischendurch höher oder niedriger.
Insofern muss man da genau hingucken, wenn man jetzt Kurse anguckt und was bedeutet
das, wenn jetzt die Zinsen hochgehen oder die Zinsen.
Und die Werte bestimmter Staatsanleihen jetzt rauf oder runter gehen,
das kann dann halt die gegenteilige Ursache haben.
Aber Fakt ist, dass halt, also ich gesehen habe am Bondmarkt,
da war halt ziemlich viel Volatilität, also viel rauf und runter,
was in sich auch nicht gut ist, aber war jetzt nicht, also kein jetzt Trend,
wo ich sagen würde, oh mein Gott, was ist hier los?
So, es ist zwischenzeitlich mal auseinandergegangen, aber was wirklich sehr
bemerkenswert ist, ist,
dass wenn man den Dow Jones Industrial Average, also den Aktienindex,
den wichtigsten in der USA mit dem DAX vergleicht, im Vergleich zu vor sechs Monaten.
Wenn man da null setzt oder 100% setzt, hat in den letzten sechs Monaten der
Dow Jones Index ungefähr 6% an Wert verloren, also Aktien,
während der DAX fast 20%, also 19,4% gewonnen hat.
Und das ist doch ungewöhnlich.
Und das ist vielleicht der beste Indikator im Moment.
Wie sehr denn internationale Investoren gerade Vertrauen in deutsche Unternehmen
haben und in amerikanische Unternehmen oder in die deutsche Wirtschaft oder
die amerikanische Wirtschaft.
Jetzt über die deutsche Wirtschaft kann man viel lästern aber im Moment ist es so, dass,
das Vertrauen in die deutsche Wirtschaft gegenüber der US-Wirtschaft massiv angestiegen ist.
Und wenn es nur die Rüstungsindustrie ist.
Ja, aber das macht Deutschland ja traditionell gut.
Aber lass uns nicht so sehr jetzt in Finanzpolitik festkleben,
weil mir ging es ja eigentlich um einen anderen Aspekt.
Also diese ganzen Kapriolen haben dazu geführt, dass die Welt mit dem Kopf schüttelt
und sagt, Leute, es reicht jetzt einfach.
Also ihr seid einfach nur Anti, ihr seid überhaupt gar kein Partner mehr.
Ihr seid einfach nur noch so ein Mafia-Clan, der irgendwie sich nehmen will, was ist.
Und dann darüber hinaus seid ihr auch noch total inkompetent und habt keine
Ahnung, was ihr da alles mit dem Arsch einreißt.
Und jetzt bilden sich halt neue Allianzen und diese Allianzen sind für meinen
Eindruck noch nicht klar sichtbar.
Vielleicht kommen sie auch nicht wirklich, aber es ist auf jeden Fall Gespräch am Start.
Und wenn man sich jetzt mal die Hauptplayer anschaut erstmal ist da Europa und
wenn ich Europa sage, meine ich halt jetzt nicht nur die EU,
sondern ich meine halt wirklich das ganze Europa außer Russland,
und hier kommt es erstmal zu einer vorsichtigen Annäherung zwischen UK und EU
immer noch so eine heiße Kartoffel und dieser Kirstama ist auch wirklich.
Ein mutloser Typ, muss man sagen.
Es ist einfach traurig, wie wenig der aus dieser Situation macht,
anstatt einfach die Gelegenheit zu nutzen und hier wieder die Gräben zuzuschütten.
Klar, sie reden und so weiter, aber es gibt keine klare Ansage,
wie was zum Beispiel mal total sinnvoll wäre, ist, dass UK jetzt der Zollunion beitritt.
Wo sogar die Türkei drin ist. Ja, das würde total Sinn machen.
Das würde vor allem ihre Grenzprobleme, ihren Grenzverkehr, den Truckverkehr
speziell an den Fähren enorm vereinfachen, ihnen unglaublich viel Geld sparen.
Einfach nur, wenn sie dieser Zollunion beitreten und über kurz oder lang werden
sie das sowieso tun müssen.
Aber passiert halt noch nicht. Trotzdem gerade jetzt das Gespräch über Rüstung
und europäische Aufrüstung und Produktion von Waffensystemen in Europa.
Das führt uns natürlich auch wieder mal klar vor Augen, was denn eigentlich
dieser Rüstungsprozess ist in Europa.
Und wir hatten jetzt in den letzten Jahrzehnten immer sehr viel Produktion gehabt,
die sehr national ausgerichtet war.
Also alle versuchen dann in irgendeiner Form ihr Ding zu ziehen.
Okay, es gibt MBDA, ist das die richtige Aufkürzung?
Also Airbus Group und so weiter. Da steckt ja auch UK mit drin,
aber vor allem halt Frankreich und so weiter.
Aber alle sehen jetzt irgendwie ein, wenn wir nicht in irgendeiner Form einen
Weg finden, ein europäisch orientiertes Beschaffungssystem zu machen und einen
europäischen Waffenstandard zu haben.
Ich meine, es gibt ohnehin NATO-Standards etc., aber das lässt sich ja alles
noch weiter verbessern.
Also das ist sozusagen schon mal eine Allianz, die jetzt einiges,
glaube ich, von unten antreibt. Die nächste Ebene ist natürlich politische Allianz.
Also inwiefern kann sich jetzt Europa weiter zusammenschließen?
Da würde ich halt sagen, gerade schwierig.
Man muss jetzt mal gucken, ob Herr Merz da genug, weiß ich nicht,
politisches Vermögen hat.
Ich habe da so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, aber es wäre halt schon mal sehr
wichtig, dass Deutschland vielleicht mal wieder eine Rolle spielt so in der europäischen Politik.
Von Scholz könnte man das ja jetzt nicht gerade behaupten, da hat eigentlich
gar nichts vorangebracht. Merkel ja vorher eigentlich auch nicht.
Das wäre halt wichtig ja und die andere Frage ist halt auch,
wie steht die Ukraine jetzt da, also ist das jetzt sozusagen für die Ukraine
eine Chance ich denke schon, wie siehst du das.
Ja also ich sehe es ist auf jeden Fall eine Riesenchance für Europa so,
ja einfach diese Diese,
wir hatten das ja beim letzten Mal, wie gesagt, 650 Millionen Europäer,
inklusive Ukraine und Türkei jetzt, wenn man das rechnet,
650 Millionen Europäer, die sich von 360 Millionen Amerikanern vor 140 Millionen
Russen beschützen lassen, die mit 40 Millionen Ukrainern nicht klarkommen.
Und das und da denke ich ist auf jeden Fall also sagen wir so, ich glaube es wird Zeit,
dass die USA vielleicht bei der Produktion von Sicherheit sprich dass sie halt,
halb so viel oder genauso viel Rüstungsausgaben hat, wie der ganze Rest der
Welt, dass das ein Ende hat.
Und das zu erreichen wird schwierig und komplex und schmerzhaft für die USA
werden, Aber eigentlich,
vielleicht öffnet das nach einer Phase jetzt größerer Unruhe und mehr Kriegen,
eröffnet das vielleicht dann die Möglichkeit,
dass tatsächlich allgemeine Abrüstung global stattfindet.
Weil gesagt, du brauchst eigentlich nur halb so viele Waffen wie dein Nachbar,
um Sicherheit, um sicher zu sein.
Und deswegen theoretisch, wenn alle das verstehen würden, würde jeder permanent
abrüsten, weil dann würde es zu einem Abrüstungswettlauf kommen.
Und den würde ich ja gerne sehen langfristig, weil ja,
also vielleicht in ferner Zukunft schaffen wir dann einen Abrüstungswettlauf zu initiieren.
Na gut, bevor wir jetzt so sehr in Spekulationen und Philosophien abgleiten,
wir sagen erstmal den Deckel drauf hier auf unser Update,
ich bin gespannt was passieren wird.
Also die Aussichten haben sich
jetzt für die Ukraine weder nennenswert verbessert noch verschlechtert.
Und wir werden halt sehen, für Russland natürlich die große Katastrophe ist,
dass die von Trump angezettelte Wirtschaftskrise jetzt den Ölpreis so in den Keller treibt.
Und das für sich genommen könnte vielleicht die singuläre Maßnahme sein,
die Russland dann dazu zwingt, den Krieg zu beenden.
Das ist vielleicht etwas konkreter und weniger spekulativ.
Ich bin noch nicht ganz davon überzeugt, dass der Ölpreis alleine nicht ausreicht,
aber es stimmt natürlich schon,
derzeit liegt der Ölpreis unter 60 US-Dollar, sowas, also wenn er unter 60 liegt
und ich glaube er liegt derzeit sogar noch tiefer,
dann reicht das eben nicht für das russische Budget.
Die kriegen einfach ihren Staatshaushalt nicht finanziert.
Aber ich glaube, die Russen sind auch noch in der Lage, lange Zeit auf dem Zahnfleisch weiterzumachen.
Irgendwann werden sie aber natürlich Probleme bekommen und ich denke,
dass der wirtschaftliche Druck einer von zwei Faktoren ist, mit dem man halt
Russland in die Knie zwingen kann und sollte. Der andere ist halt der militärische Druck.
Was anderes verstehen die halt nicht. Es ist halt nur Geld und Waffen.
Tut mir leid. Man kann sich natürlich auch immer hinstellen und sagen,
es wäre aber schön, wenn es anders wäre.
Ja, wäre schön. Aber ich glaube halt nicht dran, dass irgendetwas anderes dort
zu einem Stimmungswandel führen kann. Es muss einfach eine militärische Niederlage
sein, gepaart mit einer wirtschaftlichen Niederlage.
Und das ist halt auch der Grund, warum sie überhaupt so...
Und warum sie gar nicht aufhören können, Krieg zu führen. Also Putin kann nicht
aufhören, Krieg zu führen.
Würde der Krieg jetzt enden, Russland würde sofort in ein wirtschaftliches Desaster stürzen.
Weil derzeit halt einfach durch diese ganzen staatsfinanzierten Militärinvestitionen
die Wirtschaft überhaupt noch am Leben erhalten ist, während halt alle Preise
steigen, Gehälter steigen,
die Workforce sich reduziert, es läuft halt alles auf so einen kritischen Bereich zurück.
Aber sogar die USA hatten Schwierigkeiten nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg,
sich wirtschaftlich wieder zu fangen.
Es dauert eine Weile, bis du die Wirtschaft wieder umgestellt hast auf eine
normale Friedensproduktion.
Und von daher wird es halt schwierig für Russland.
Ja, also wie gesagt, Ölpreis jetzt deutlich unter 60, so gut,
je nachdem, was man sieht, also um die 60 Dollar.
Aber runter von, ja, im Januar waren es noch 80, ja, so, im März waren es noch 70 teilweise.
Und also das, wenn das jetzt bleibt und da spricht viel, achso,
was dazu kommt ist, dass die OPEC auch noch beschlossen hat,
die Produktion auszuweiten.
Was die Preise dann nochmal nach unten schickt, ja.
Ja, und insofern kann man nur kann man nur hoffen, dass diese ja unbeabsichtigten
Nebenwirkungen von Trumps Politik dann den Krieg beenden, weil ja,
seine qualifizierten Verhandler nicht dazu in der Lage sein.
Es könnte sein, dass er rein zufällig den Krieg beendet.
Versehentlich.
Sorry. Wo war das Ihr Krieg? Den habe ich gerade umgestoßen.
Alright. Wir machen jetzt hier Ende.
Vielen Dank. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. ihr Leute da draußen.
Ich freue mich immer sehr, dass ihr das hier annehmt, unser,
Beobachtungsprogramm und ja, wir gucken mal, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wir,
nicht wieder sechs Wochen verstreichen lassen bis zum nächsten Mal,
weil ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl,
da passiert jetzt demnächst wieder ein bisschen mehr. Warten wir es ab.
Ja, solange schlagen wir es mal ein bisschen mit der neuen Bundesregierung rum.
Ja und falls Interesse an einem USA-Special besteht, wenn ich mir jetzt noch
drei Wochen hier unterwegs bin und dann vielleicht mal etwas qualifizierter
meine Erfahrungen zusammenfassen.
Genau, das könnt ihr ja in die Kommentare reinschreiben. Die lesen wir immer gerne.
Jetzt machen wir aber wirklich mal Schluss. Bis bald. Tschüss.
Macht's gut. Ciao.